nous allons évoquer ce matin dans le
cadre de notre cycle concernant
l'Afrique les enjeux de de notre défense
en en Afrique alors que vous le savez le
président de la République a annoncé une
réorganisation d'ensemble de notre
présence militaire sur le sur le
continent africain donc comme vous le
savez dans le cadre de ce cycle on a une
première approche assez
multidimensionnelle dans un premier
temps et dans un second temps on on va
s'intéresser davantage de manière plus
précise aux questions sécuritaires au
travers de nobas au travers de nos
opérations au travers des opérations de
maintien de la paix au travers du rôle
des entreprises de sécurité et et de
défense lors d'une précédente audision
HH MMB avec avait évoqué devant notre
audition l'idée finalement d'un d'un
d'un nouveau cycle dans lequel l'Afrique
est lancé et a développé l'idée de d'une
juste
distance et donc c'est peut-être un des
points que vous pourrez
aborder aujourd'hui sur votre
appréciation sur les critiques portées
sur la politique africaine de de de la
France qui potentiell qui ont qui se
sont fait jour ces ces derniers mois sur
le la m avec la multiplication des des
des coups d'État euh et pour nous en
parler ce matin nous avons le plaisir
d'accueillir trois chercheurs que je
remercie à nouveau pour leur présence
aujourd'hui Monsieur Alain antil qui est
à ma droite qui est directeur du Centre
Affrique subsaharienne de de l'IFRI vous
êtes spécialiste des questions de
sécurité au au sel on a d'ailleurs
l'occasion d'échanger ensemble depuis de
nombreuses années vous enseignez à
l'Institut d'Études Politiques de Lille
et à l'université parisen pteron Sorbon
vous aurez sans doute accord de partager
votre analyse sur l'avenir de notre
présence au salet en Afrique de l'Ouest
alors que les discours antifrançais s'y
multiplient madame Sonia le gourer LEC
vous êtes docteur en sciences politiques
et maîtresse de conférence à
l'Université Catholique de Lille vos
travaux portent principalement sur les
problématiques de paix et de sécurité
dans la Corne de de l'Afrique vous
pourouvez peut-être revenir sur les
enjeux propres à la côte test et à la
corne de de l'Afrique dont on parle
moins mais où les enjeux sont
extrêmement importants on l' encore vu
ces ces derniers jours et vous le savez
mes chers collègues cette partie abrite
notamment la base de Djibouti
stratégique pour l'influence de la
France dans l'Indopacifique notre
collègue Jean-Charles lassonor était
récemment et vous savez que il y a une
renégociation en cours du tcmd donc on
est là encore vraiment dans l'actualité
et enfin Monsieur Abdel Nour Benantar
j'espère que je prononce bien votre nom
vous êtes professeur à l'Université
Paris 8 chargé d'enseignement à Sciences
pot et chercheur associé à la frs la
Fondation pour la recherche stratégique
vos travaux de recherche pent
essentiellement sur les questions de
sécurité de défense en Méditerranée et
au Magreb alors que la France ne possède
pas de base permanente au maghreèb le
discours antifrançais n'en sont pas
moins présents dans certains états aussi
nous serions heureux de vous entendre
sur la manière de valoriser d'avantage
l'aspect multidimensionnel de nos
partenariats pour contribuer ensemble à
la sécurisation de cette région voilà
madames messieurs je vous laisse
désormais la parole sans plus tarder sur
ces points et puis l'ensemble des sujets
que vous souhaiteriez aborder la parole
est à Monsieur al antil je crois pour
une durée de 10
minutes merci d'abord pour cette
invitation je suis très heureux de
partager avec vous quelques quelques
points de vue sur sur l'Afrique
subsaharienne en particulier sur le
Sahel et et l'Afrique de l'Ouest mon
propos sera organisé autour de trois
points le dans dans un premier temps je
vais revenir sur les évolutions
sécuritaires en Afrique de l'Ouest euh
ces derniers ces derniers mois dans un
deuxième temps je vais je vais faire un
retour sur la politique française
vis-à-vis de du du Sahel dont la
composante militaire était importante et
dans un troisième temps je vais revenir
sur les changements
géopolitiques qui s'accélèrent dans
cette zone comme dans le reste de
l'Afrique
sub-saharienne
euh l'évolution c'est sécuritaire du du
Sahel et de l'Afrique de l'Ouest on peut
le le décrire de manière disons
rapide en quelques
points la situation sécuritaire s'est
dégradé depuis les pouches dans dans
tant au Mali qu'au BurkinaFaso et
maintenant au
Niger ça c'est la première constatation
donc les pouvoirs militaires ne sont pas
en mesure en tout cas pour l'instant
n'ont pas fait la preuve qu'ils étaient
plus efficaces que les pouvoirs civils
qu'ils ont renversés euh le nombre
d'attaques et de VI d'attaques et de
victimes euh a augmenté ces dernières
années dans les dans les dans les trois
pays et on a vu une accélération par
exemple sur le sur le Niger très très
clair depuis le PCH de du 26 du 26
juillet
euh non seulement on a cette évolution
je dirais chiffrée qu'on suit à travers
des des des des des bases de données
mais mais on voit aussi par exemple
qu'au Mali
euh les depuis début début du mois de
septembre on a des attaques régulières
contre des cibles dures c'est-à-dire
contre des bases militaires maliennes
par des groupes par des groupes
djihadistes euh généralement dans la
communication de l'armée malienne euh
celle-ci dit que ils ont repoussé les
attaques mais en réalité ces attaques
ont comme pour but à la fois du hum iler
le le le le l'armée malienne mais aussi
de récupérer des armements et de
repartir de la base ce qui finalement
arrange le le le le discours officiel
qui dit généralement que l'on a repoussé
ces ces attaques alors quels sont les
extension possible
euh de ce foyer djihadiste implanté
enfin de ces multiples foyer djihadistes
implanté dans le dans le Sahel central
euh au sud et à partir du sud et de
l'ouest malien on a on peut on pourrait
avoir dans les dans les mois ou dans les
années à venir des des percés vers vers
la Mauritanie l'est du Sénégal et le
nord de la Guinée ce que je dis là et
sont des conjectures donc elles peuvent
très bien ne pas se réaliser mais il y a
il y a un potentiel de d'extension vers
ces vers ces zone à partir du Sud du
birkina il y a une extension vers les p
PS du Golfe de Guinée qui sont déjà
disons qui sont déjà étudiés par de
multiples chercheurs pour l'instant ce
qu'on peut dire c'est
que les Pera vers les pays du Golf de
Guinée sont géographiquement très
limités en Côte d'Ivoire au au au Ghana
et au et au Togo par contre la situation
au Niger et pas au Niger mais au Bénin
est plus et plus difficile
l'implantation des groupes est il est
véritable le les zones touchées par les
violences sont sont se sont étendu
depuis 2 ans
h pour compléter ce ce tableau deux
derniers points sur les aspects
sécuritaires en en Afrique de l'Ouest il
y a le cas spécifique du nigerria où
évidemment qui est
touché de nombreux états de de cet état
confédéré sont touchés par des violence
on a tous en tête évidemment la la
dynamique Boko Haram mais au nord-ouest
euh ces deux dernières années la grande
la grande le grand problème sécuritaire
c'est la structuration de d'armée de
bandits dans le nord-ouest certains
états du nord-ouest du pays et et quand
je dis que c'est un véritable problème
on estime qu'il y a au minimum 30000
bandits qui sont qui qui ont la capacité
d'enercler des villes moyennes et de
lever le siège quand celle-ci verse un
un un un impô
donc on est dans une situation vous
voyez au au au Sahel en exagérant à
peine je dirais qu'on peut aujourd'hui
partir de la frontière
mauritanomaliienne et aller jusqu'au lac
Tchad en traversant des zones en faisant
des détours mais en traversant des zones
qui sont pratiquement toutes
euh non contrôlées par les
États voilà un petit peu ce qui se ce
qui se dessine euh et le le dernier
point que je voulais évoquer et ça n'a
échappé à personne et ça a été mentionné
par par par Thomas
gassillou c'est un affaiblissement des
en tout cas une fragilisation des des
des des pouvoirs
civils là je veux faire une une liste de
de ces trois dernières années des des
pches et des tentatives de PCH qui ont
eu lieu en Afrique de l'Ouest au Mali 2
au Niger 2 au Burkina Faso 2 en Guinée
conakri en sierraaléone et Bur et et et
Guinée
Bissao donc c'est j'ai additionné j'ai
j'ai rassemblé tentative de PCH avéré
et et PCH
réussi donc on est dans une phase très
particulière de de fragilisation des des
des pouvoirs civils avec une tentation
des des appareils militaire de
d'intervenir dans le champ politique le
deuxème point que je voulais aborder
c'est le retour sur le le lourd
investissement politique français au
Sahel quand je dis lourd il a été il a
été important du point de vue
sécuritaire mais aussi du point de vue
diplomatique il y a d'indéiables succès
tactiques qui ont été
réalisés on le soune pas assez mais
l'opération Serval a été un grand succès
ensuite l'opération Barc qui est
beaucoup critiqué à à tout de même
permis de de durement éprouver les les
principaux
salafi djihadist qui était présent dans
les zones d'intervention évidemment de
de de Barkan
et l'appui aérien proposé par la France
a permis pendant plusieurs années
que que les groupes armé soit en in
capacité de se de se réunir en grand
nombre pour attaquer des des cibles
dures ou des ou des ou des villes avec
le le retrait de du partenaire français
cette disons cette cette cette
couverture aérienne est imparfaitement
comblée par les par les les achats de
drones que l'on a vu dans les pays dans
les pays
saéliens alors pour revenir sur le
maintenant sur des aspects critique non
pas de barcane en tant que tel mais de
la politique française vis-à-vis de
cette zone
euh on voit et je vais pas m'étendre
dessus on pourra revenir dans la dans la
dans le dans le débat
euh une grande difficulté du partenaire
français à lire ce qui se passait
politiquement chez les partenaires
saélien notamment une incapacité à
voir que la présence de Barkan était de
plus en plus impopulaire et aurait à
terme des un impact politique sur ces
pays ça c'était prévisible ça a été
prévu par des chercheurs ou par même
même en terne dans certains ministères
il y a eu des des des des des des
avertissements mais ça n'a pas été ça
n'a pas été intégré à la à la décision
politique
euh deuxème point de critique on a aidé
des appareils sécuritaires euh et des
régimes qui étaient massivement
corrompus et on n'a pas vu pendant et
c'est pas de la faute de de la France
évidemment mais on n pas vu pendant
cette présence militaire majeure de de
la France
une évolution positive dans les
pratiques corrctives de ces appareils
sécuritaires là aussi je je développe
pas c'est c'est il y a une littérature
là
là-dessus donc à un moment donné il y
avait cette cette question qui a qui a
pas été tout à fait
[Musique]
adresser trème
point de disons de critique là encore un
problème de lecture de niveau politique
c'est que on n pas anticipé que au
Burkina et au
Mali la classe politique qui était au
pouvoir qu'elle soit d'ailleurs civile
ou militaire elle était dans un dans une
vision de l'avenir très très pessimiste
et c'est des gens qui craignent pour la
la cohésion de leur pays à terme
c'est-à-dire que les les les les
appareils d'État contrôlent un
territoire de plus en plus restreint de
le partie de leur territoire de plus en
plus restreint aujourd'hui au Burkina
FO l'État et son appareil sécuritaire
contrôle peut-être 30 ou 40 % du
territoire
effectivement et ce sont des des des
régimes qui sont en train de de enfin
qui imaginent le pire et qui sont cap et
qui à un moment donné avait des besoins
que la France ne pouvait pas leur leur
offrir à savoir des Liv livraisons
d'armes massives c'était ça qui qui qui
était demandé euh et aussi une capacité
pour les les les militaires de passer à
des pratiques de contreinsurrection
classique très brutale et sans droit
international humanitaire ce que la
France ne pouvait accepter parce qu'elle
aura été évidemment éminemment critiquée
dans les instances internationales si
elle avait appuyer une armée qui faisait
des massacres dans des
villages donc ça c'est c'était des
points il y avait une espèce de voilà de
décalage de plus en plus fort notamment
au Burkina Faso mais surtout au Mali sur
sur ces deux points-là des demandes
qu'on ne pouvait pas adresser parce que
pour des raisons politiques internes
euh le dernier point que l'on ne mesure
pas peut-être encore assez c'est que la
France a évidemment engagé beaucoup de
moyens militaires mais a aussi engagé
énormément de moyens diplomatiques pour
le Sahel et elle a été chef de fil des
de la communauté internationale et en
particulier des Européens
euh appui au G5 Sahel création de
l'Alliance sel la Coalition pour le
Sahel du p3s
et finalement tout ça a attiré les
Européens à à intervenir notamment dans
le cadre de la minusma et cette
cette ce C disons ce ce retrait des
Français du Sahel à la demande des Sahel
lien va impacter évidemment le le le
poids de la France dans les institutions
européennes comme leader vis-à-vis du
continent africain ça c'est c'est c'est
quelque chose aussi qu'il faut avoir en
têteux dans quelques oui tuux oui oui
j'ai j'ai la trisème partie sera assez
assez rapide et
ramassé sur les changements
géopolitiques rapide que l'on a
actuellement création de de l'Alliance
pour pour pour le
Sahel l'allance des états du Sahel donc
trois pays du Sahel qui sortte du G5 et
qui menace peut-être à terme l' mooa et
la la CDAO la Russie qui investit
massivement politiquement et maintenant
militairement dans cette dans cette zone
les Russes sont pas instigateurs de ce
qui s'est passé politiquement au Sahel
mais ils appuient en armes au soutien
contre insurrectionnel et et à la
stabilisation à la protection des des
régimes maintenant ils ont une offre
assez complète d'un point de vue
sécuritaire donc ça c'est de plus en
plus regardé étudié apprécié en Afrique
subsaharienne et je finirai par le le le
point suivant si je regarde la presse
internationale je je voulais vous quen
quelques semaines il s'est passé des
choses quand même assez intéressantes à
l'instigation du Mali il y a eu un
rapprochement entre des officiels Russes
et des officiels nigériens euh
on voit au depuis la fin novembre on en
parler en Russie de la naissance d'un
corps
africain c'est-à-dire d'une partie de
l'armée russe qui sera dédiée aux
partenaires africains pour l'instant
c'est en gestation mais on a des des des
des papiers de de presse qui commencent
euh le maire de la ville de thè au
Sénégal a enclenché un jumelage avec la
ville de Sébastopol en Crimée
euh l'Ukraine a décidé de d'être plus
présente sur en Afrique pour contrer la
la Russie euh le président
biélorusse fait des visite officielle en
en Afrique subsaharienne au Ken au Kenya
et en Guinée équatoriale il vous
échappera pas que la la politique
africaine de la Biélorussie était pour
l'instant en tout cas pour nous euh
chercheurs qui somm faillibles une
espèce d'inconnu
euh et enfin on apprend il y a quelques
semaines que la Hongrie va envoyer des
soldats au
Tchad évidemment je dis pas que ces
événements que je je je viens de
mentionner sont en cohérence mais il
dessine un paysage en évolution rapide
euh qu'il faut prendre en compte
euh cet environnement géopolitique
change rapidement euh il y a une demande
de plus en plus croissante de protection
des régimes donc il faut que qu'on se
positionne vis-à-vis de de de de ces
questions
euh voilà je pourrais revenir sur chacun
des points évidemment dans dans la
discussion merci merci beaucoup pour
cette intervention la parole est
désormais à Sonia
leourielec euh bonjour monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés je vous remercie de cette
invitation à échanger sur la ou les
politiques de défense de la France dans
la ou Les Afriques vous vous l'aviez
mentionné lors d'une précédente audition
euh c'est une question essentielle
importante pour notre pays euh la France
se retrouve aujourd'hui entre l'embarras
de choisir une ligne politique claire et
la difficulté de plus en plus forte de
peser sur les événements sur le
continent et il me semble que la
question du pourquoi de notre politique
en Afrique est souvent moins questionné
que celle du comment euh nous sommes sur
le continent or si la France se pense
comme une une puissance elle se doit
d'identifier ses intérêts et les valeurs
qu'elle souhaite défendre sur le
continent africain et la cohérence de
notre réponse doit se faire également
avec nos partenaires sur le continent
comme l'a rappelé Arthur banga
précédemment donc je vous propose une
réflexion en trois temps d'abord
quelques constats généraux puis
l'importance me semble-t-il d'avoir des
politiques de défense différentes sur le
continent africain et en particulier sur
la côte est-africaine au cœur de grandes
transformation du système international
aujourd'hui et on verra que le paysage
se transforme beaucoup comme tu viens
aussi de te rappeler Alain qui je su je
partage les les éléments qui viennent
d'être présentés alors il semblerait que
nous assistons effectivement à un
rejet en à l'ouest en tout cas et une
impasse pour notre politique de défense
toutes les questions toutes les actions
de la France sont soupçonnées d'être des
instruments d'impérialisme de néoc
néocolonialisme ce sont des termes qui
reviennent fréquemment et plus
globalement nous parlons d'un continent
à la population très jeune qui exprime
de différentes
façons la démocratie et l'importance
pour elle de défendre ses droits les
entités qui se reconnaissent dans ce que
parfois on appelle le sud global ou l'
Sud dénonce des discours à double
standard des Occidentaux une forme de
néosouverainisme est ainsi portée par
les pays du Sud global et en Afrique en
particulier qui avant qui invoque le
principe d'équivalence morale
les interventions militaires au Sahel en
Libye avant en Irak et cetera sont
dénoncé comme de l'ingérence et vécu
dans ces pays et notamment chez les
jeunes comme une manifestation d'un
impérialisme occidental sur les
questions internationales alors ce
dernier point rejoint également un
sentiment parfois d'humiliation qu'on
retrouve beaucoup dans les discours de
nombreux pays qui estiment perdre une
partie de leur souverainté en se
soumettant aux politiques des
institutions financières internationales
ou du droit international comme tu l'as
rappelé et donc on les forcerait à
répondre à des conditionnalités
politiques que des pays comme la Russie
ou la Chine ne ne leur demande pas
nécessairement et ben l'une des réponses
de la France est de diluer sa présence
en ayant une empreinte plus discrète de
multilatéraliser d'européaniser pour
légitimer le maintien de sa présence et
ses intérêts propres pourtant il me
semble important de penser notre
politique de défense sur le continent au
pluriel puisque l'Afrique est un
continent très grand avec des dynamiques
parfois très différentes et donc il me
semble qu'il faut avoir des politiques
de défense et ce que je semble
identifier comme un peut-être un trou
dans la raquette entre
guillemets c'est que j'inviterai à
l'ouverture hors du champ traditionnel
francophone ou Afrique de l'Ouest et
cetera ça n'est pas nouveau on le fait
de plus en plus notamment dans le
domaine économique mais l'idée c'est de
corréler capacités militairees et
intérêt économique nous devons
clairement identifier nos intérêt intêt
pour les défendre quelles sont-ils à
l'Est je dirais effectivement
l'Indo-Pacifique qui est une priorité
qui a été déclaré comme une priorité
mais souvent la côte Est Africaine est
délaissée dans cette stratégie la France
dans l'Union européenne peut-être
pourtant une nation cadre pour porter le
projet Indo-Pacifique puisque depuis le
brexit les territoires ultramarins de
l'Union européenne sont à 95 %
français la liberté de circulation vous
aura pas échapper notamment en mer Rouge
est une priorité et aujourd'hui l'enjeu
qu'on voit s'y dérouler c'est une
exportation enfin aussi une une une
affirmation du du conflit
israëlo-palestinien avec vous l'avez vu
ces dernières semaines et ces derniers
jours voir ces dernières heures des
attaques outils sur des navires
notamment des navires commerciaux ou
pétroliers
dans dans le sur la mer Rouge que la
présence française a permis de protéger
certains navires et la présence
américaine
également vous avez de nombreux acteurs
qui cherchent aujourd'hui à contrôler la
mer Rouge que ce soit les ports de la
mer Rouge et on retrouve
principalement les les Émirats arabes
unis qui contrôlent une partie de ces
ports les pays du golf en général et il
me semble qu'il ne faut pas quand si on
a une ambition pour l'Indopacifique
délaisser cet espace et le laisser
également à la Chine qui est très
présente puisque la Corne de l'Afrique
fait partie des routes maritime de la
fameuse initiative belten Road
initiative lancée en 2013 et que la
Chine est présente à Djibouti
militairement depuis 2017 l'idée étant
d'intégrer cette région donc dans la les
routes de la soie et notamment derrière
Djibouti et son million d'habitants ce
sont les 120 millions d'habitants de
l'Éthiopie plus largement si on prend la
COMESA plus de 500 millions d'habitants
donc c'est ça qu'il y a aussi
derrière la Russie montre aussi un
intérêt particulier pour la la mer Rouge
on a beaucoup parlé de d'une possible
présence au Soudan aujourd'hui les
rapprochements qu'on voit se faire c'est
avec l'éritrée puisque il y a eu
également un accord entre
sébastopo un agreement entre sbastopo et
le port de Massawa en éitrée et je vous
rappelle que l'éritrée est un des
derniers états totalitaires du monde euh
et qui est un trouilon de la Corne de
l'Afrique et très certainement un des
grands Isaias saferwaki son président un
des grands gant des transformations et
des conflits qui ont eu lieu dans la
Corne de l'Afrique et notamment en
Éthiopie les deux dernières années trois
dernières années donc je pense qu'il
faut prêter un œil aussi particulier à
ce qui se passe en héritrée qui est à la
frontière djibouienne alors l'idée
aujourd'hui c'est que Djibouti est notre
puivot et notre est un centre important
pour la France et nous aurons sûrement
des annonces demain ou je ne sais pas
quand sur le traité qui est en train
d'être négocié or il semble que notre
présence a parfois été un peu questionné
ce qui est un paradoxe puisque nous
sommes dans une période où tout le monde
arrive dans la Corne de l'Afrique et
tout le monde arrive à Djibouti donc il
peut-être étonnant de se questionner sur
notre présence puisque Djibouti est un
facteur de puissance pour la France
c'est une puissance pour la France et
pour être une puissance souveraine et
c'est un acteur qui nous permet d'être
un acteur de sécurité aussi dans l'océan
Indien pu je vous rappelle que
contrairement à l'océan Atlantique la
liberté de navigation y est plus menacée
que dans dans l'océan atthentique euh
vous avez la à la fois la problématique
de la piraterie même si elle a beaucoup
baissé voire il n'y a presque plus
d'actes de piraterie mais comme je vous
l'ai expliqué pour la mer Rouge je crois
qu'on revient à une guerre de course
puisque les Iraniens seraient a priori
très fortement derrière le soutien et le
le le matériel que les outils possèdent
pour attaquer les les navires mais on
observe également du trafic d'armes du
trafic d' piacier et cetera et cetera
dans dans la région et ce qui est
intéressant à à contrairement à
l'Afrique de l'Ouest c'est la France a
un avantage concurrentiel dans la région
et ne subit pas encore le fardeau de
l'histoire je ne crois pas qu'il y ait
beaucoup de sentiments anti-français
encore à Djibouti ou dans la Corne de
l'Afrique donc il semble essentiel de
conserver une présence militaire dans
cet espace puisque c'est aussi une zone
d'appui pour organiser des opérations
pour sécuriser les Français et les
Européens comme on l'a vu pour évacuer
les personnes qui étaient au Soudan la
limite de cette approche et de la
importance qu'à la Corne de l'Afrique et
l'Afrique de l'Est c'est que nous sommes
aussi dans une région avec de nombreux
conflits une instabilité forte je vous
rappelle que nous avons des régimes très
forts dans la région qui a une
transition politique qui est entamée
depuis 2020 que ce soit en Éthiopie dans
quelques années sûrement à Djibouti et
euh et que donc bah il faut que la
France se positionne aussi avec ces ces
transformations l'Éthiopie nous avons
qui est la puissance régionale nous
avons beaucoup de craintte en tant que
chercheur sur l'évolu ution de la
situation en Éthiopie certains juristes
ont évoqué une politique génocidaire du
Premier ministre Haby Ahmed détenteur du
prix Nobel de la Paix contre la
population tigréenne et si un accord de
paix a été trouvé l'année dernière le
conflit est loin d'être terminé
puisqu'il semble compliqué de d'établir
une justice à la suite de ce de ce
conflit et les armes ne se sont pas tu
puisque le conflit perturbe avec les
amaras donc une partie de la
population dans dans dans ce pays donc
la la situation est très critique en
Éthiopie et je vous rappelle c'est
intéresse en particulier les Français
carby Ahmed a émis son souhait d'avoir
un accès à la mer Rouge et un accès à la
mer en général or le pays est enclavé et
donc tous les voisins de l'Éthiopie se
sont interrogé sur cette demande euh
puisque ben ça pourrait viser aussi les
Djibouti euh déjà en 2015 l'ancien
Premier ministre éthiopien disait qu'il
fallait aller au-delà de l'intégration
économique avec Djibouti et aller vers
une intégration politique ce qui avait
beaucoup inquiété les dibouiens et donc
les derniers propos et déclarations d'AB
Ahmed et sa vision de de la puissance
éthiopienne comme ayant un accès à la
mer peut inquiéter les éitréens les
djibouiens les Somaliens et et
cetera c'est un peu les limites et les
les les questions à se poser dans les
années qui viennent alors effectivement
euh la pandémie le recul de la
démocratie sur le continent africain et
en Afrique de l'Est en particulier euh
dans le monde et les changements
climatiques également modifie
radicalement le contexte le nord ou
enfin nous n ne sommes plus
nécessairement entendus lorsque nous
défendons la démocratie parce que les
défaillances de nos propres démocraties
ne rendent plus audible ce discours
auprès notamment d'une certaine jeunesse
dans la en Afrique et dans la Corne de
l'Afrique et nous sommes au défi
aujourd'hui de répondre à un autre récit
qui est proposé au sud global qui
ambitionne une une émancipation de toute
forme de domination en proposant de
nouvelles formes euh de convergence et
l'insturation d'un ordre international
différent et notamment de proposer euh
un ordre international politique
financier commercial alternatif ou
complémentaire à celui qui existe
actuellement et le les limites de ce
nouvel arrangement sont clair c'est une
manipulation parfois de ce récit par des
acteurs qui ont des ambitions
hégémoniques je pense à la Chine et à la
Russie qui mettent en récit ces
revendications du Sud global euh et
propose des modèles alternatifs et leur
Audi est de plus en plus importante
notamment depuis la guerre en Ukraine
donc je conclurai juste en disant que il
me semble important et on pourra y
revenir de penser l'Afrique dans sa
diversité d'avoir des politiques de
défense de ne pas le voir comme un bloc
homogène Les Afriques sont pleinement
entrés dans le 21e siècle et ont intégré
largement le système international et
les dynamiques du système international
à nous de faire de même avec notre
politique ou nos politiques africaines
et de les entrer dans le 21e siècle
c'estex nous disait que les vents ne
sont favorables qu'à celui qui sait où
il va et il me semble que nous devons
conserver cet adage en tête merci merci
beaucoup pour cette intervention qui
appellera sans doute beaucoup de
questions la parole est désormais à
Monsieur abdanour Benantar pour nous
parler davantage de du Magreb après
l'Afrique de l'Ouest après la Corne de
l'Afrique on revient un peu plus au
nord-ouest merci monsieur le Président
euh bonjour madame messieurs alors euh
mes propos vont donc concernés
essentiellement le Maghreb mais je
commencerai par quelques remarques
d'ordre général des remarques
préliminaires la première euh
commencerit par une question
intervenir ne pas intervenir agir ne pas
agir telle est la question et je pense
que que la France a intérêt à intégrer
un dilemme structurel dans sa politique
africaine qui eu un monsong identique à
celui des États-Unis d'Amérique la
première puissance mondiale et ce dlà
mais le suivant euh lorsque je parle en
l'occurrence de la France lorsqu'elle
intervient on lui reproche euh son
néocolonialisme et lorsqu'elle
n'intervient pas on lui reproche de ne
pas assumer ses responsabilités euh
d'ancienne puissance coloniale et donc
elle agit ou elle n'agait pas dans les
deux cas de figure à
les critique donc parfois il faut il
vaut mieux agir
euh alors concernant le le Maghreb les
relation
franco-maghrébine est très complexe sont
très complexes et ne peuvent peut-être
appréandé d'un
seul les différents angles sont sont
sont interliés et donc il a il est très
difficile de dessaucier par exemple les
allias de la relation politique
algéro franco-algérienneou algéro
française
des enfin d'ocier les aspects défense et
sécurité des allias politiques comme le
démontre l'ouverture puis la fermure
puis encore à nouveau l'ouverture de de
l'espace aérien au aux forces armées
armées français française donc cette
problématique là doit être appréhandée
dans son dans dans son dans son ensemble
alors je je voudrais m'attarder
d'avantage sur sur les spécificités du
Maghreb dans ses relations avec avec la
rive nord mais dans ses dans sa propre
j'allais dire sphère maghrébine
intermaghrébine le premier point c'est
cette relation un peu complexe entre les
deux rives de la Méditerranée je je
résumerai ça par une sorte de de de
proximité
importante et immédiate y compris y
compris humaine et culturelle une
distanciation stratégique en terme de
perception stratégique le Maghreb est
toujours mis mis à distance donc il
faudra mener une réflexion je vais
revenir sur cette question de un peu
plus tard de perception le
deème deuxème point en tout les cas qui
qui dans mon intervention mais qui
concerne davantage le Maghreb c'est la
la configuration sécuritaire au Maghreb
j'emploie davantage la notion de de
sécurité que celle de défense puisque la
sécurité est plus large que la défense
donc la défense se limite
traditionnellement à la à la à la
protection du territoire national orors
la sécurité donc conçit l'idée qu'il
peut y avoir des menaces qui touchent à
la sécurité nationale mais il se trouve
à des à des milliers de de de kilomètres
du du territoire national donc il il au
Maghreb la configuration sécuritaire se
résume ainsi l'absence de de menaces
stratégiques donc des menaces d'ordre ex
existentiel aucun État ne perçoit son
voisin comme une menace à son à sa
survie c'est c'est c'est le principe de
base en matière de sécurité c'est c'est
la survie le ça c'est le premier point
le second point c'est les insécurités au
Maghreb sont essentiellement la
conséquence de la faiblesse des des
états et non de la puissance des états
comme c'est le cas un peu partout
d'ailleurs en Afrique et elles sont
aussi le résultat de l'intervention en
Libye toute intervention est vecteur par
euh définition vcteur d'instabilité donc
le l'intervention en Libye a j'allais
dire à moyen orientalisé le Maghreb le
Maghreb a toujours été une zone beaucoup
plus stable que le Moyen-Orient et
l'intervention en Libye a a mis à mal
mal cette cette cette spécificité
maghrébine le le le trisème point qui
concerne le Maghreb c'est la
problématique des des relations
algéro-marocaines et pour ce qui relève
de la défense de la sécurité évidemment
l'ARM moment les deux pays s'armment
depuis euh depuis au moins une vingtaine
d'années à un rythme très accéléré en
l'absence de justement c'est ça la
question en l'absence de menac
existentiell les budgets défense sont
colossaux je vais pas rentrer dans les
détails j'ai l'occasion de travailler
là-dessus donc sur sur les sur ces
problématiques là mais il n'en demeure
pas moins que les déterminants de ces de
cet armement est d'ordre local il est
lié à la relation à cette tension
rivalité euh structurelle entre les les
deux pays il ne concerern en aucun cas
la rive nord ou d'autres pays de la
région d'ailleurs les logiques dans dans
ces pays qui ne sont pas des des
puissances majeures les logiques
d'armement sont toujours déterminé par
des considérations régionales ou
ou srégional l'autre point concerne la
perception de de la menace
euh dès lors que on perçoit le le voisin
comme une menace on se met à armé et et
donc on entre dans ce qu'on appelle ce
ce fameux délame de de la sécurité donc
l'armement de l'un enclenche l'armement
de l'autre et et on se retrouve dans un
dans un cercle vicieux mais ce qui est
intéressant à retenir en matière de
perception de la menace c'est c'est la
réalité en fait ce qui compte ce n'est
pas la réalité telle qu'elle est mais
telle qu'elle est perçue et c'est cette
perception là qui va avoir des euh des
conséquences et là j'ouvre j'ouvre un
peu la voix sur la la rive nord euh il y
a un discours qui monte un peu une
analyse qui monte dans C certains
cercles militaire et académique
notamment au sein de certains think tank
français qui s'alarme un peu de de
l'armement de l'Algérie notamment ces
forces navales et cette fameuse
hypothèse que l'Algérie pour pourrait
avoir des capacités suffisantes pour
pour bloquer le le détroit du Gibraltar
le déé d'accès et et et et cetera c'est
une notion utilisé aux États-Unis à
partir de 2003 mais qui renvoie en fait
à une réalité une réalité très ancienne
alors le risque ici à mon sens je vais
essayer de d'être bref c'est de
construire une nouvelle menace qui
serait de mettre à jour un peu la
fameuse thèse du du discours de la
menace venue du Sud dans les années 90
au début des années 90 ce qui a conduit
par la suite les pays européens et
l'Alliance atlantique à lancer des des
dialogues en direction de la rve Sud
pour dissiper cette menace et ces
initiatives ont réussi à changer le
climat perceptuel
euh en Méditerranée même si elles n'ont
pas eu d'incidence sur les conflits non
résolus dans la région donc ça serait
une erreur de reconstruire une nouvelle
une nouvelle une nouvelle menace ou de
d'estimer qu'il y a une menace qui monte
sur la la rive sud pour diverses raisons
d'abord comme je l'ai dit l'armement est
déterminé par des considérations locales
euh deuxièmement aucun État maghriébain
y compris l'Algérie ou l'Égypte ou le
Maroc on peut citer n'importe quel État
arabe dearve Sud n'a des ne prétend à
une parité stratégique avec les les pays
de laarve Nord qui font partie de
l'alliance atlantique et qui bénéficient
tous du fameux article 5 euh 3è 3oe
point
euh ces ces pays-là euh ne sont pas
considérés ou ne prétendent pas avoir
disposer d'armes nucléaires ne sont pas
considérés comme des états proliférants
donc la menace euh n'existe pas ni au
plan conventionnel ni euh ni au plan euh
au plan d'armes de destruction massive
donc le risque c'est de revenir
euh revenir en arrière 23 ans en arrière
pour construire une une prétendue menace
euh venu de du Sud et donc ce qui va
compliquer davantage les relations les
relations entre les entre les de rive
cela m'amène cette question euh cette
remise en cause de ce discours de cette
construction de la de la menace m'amène
à la à comment faire voilà une fois on a
dit ça euh que faire je pense que
l'essentiel ce serait de de se
concentrer de se focaliser sur certaines
initiatives qui fonctionnent plus ou
moins elles ont des insuffisances
évidemment mais c'est c'est ça mérite
réflexion au lieu d'aller dans tous les
sens de lancer de lancer des initiatives
dans toutes les directions ça serait par
exemple de de se concentrer davantage
sur le forum 5 + 5 notamment le le volet
défense qui a été lancé en 2004 à
l'initiative de la France parce que
c'est c'est c'est un dispositif de
coopération régionale restreint donc
limité à la Méditerranée occidentale
donc ça limite un peu le le les risques
que ce ce dispositif soit ce soit
tributaire des des alliats politiques
dans dans l'ensemble de de de la
Méditerranée et d'aller davantage dans
dans cette dans cette piste de de
coopération
puisque ce groupe là notamment son volet
défense constitue réellement une
plateforme de socialisation régionale
entre les élites militaires et
sécuritaires euh des
des pieds des de Rives de du bassin
ouest ouest ouest
méditerranéen l'autre initiative qui
mérite aussi d'être
davantage mise en valeur valorisé c'est
le dialogue méditerranéen de de
l'Alliance atlantique même si il faudra
réfléchir évidemment sur la valeur
ajoutée de chaque dispositif pour éviter
qu'il y ait
des qui est du double emploi et
d'ailleurs le double emploi existe entre
entre ces initiative mais mais en encore
encore d'autres d'autres initiatives euh
je terminerai par des remarques d'ordre
général concernant le concernant
l'Afrique comme ça a été rappelé par mes
collègues l'Afrique est traversée par
déclévages mais elle est travailler en
profondeur la la les sociétés africaines
comme les les États les États africains
donc
il le risque peut-être dans dans cette
dans cette réflexion dans cette refonde
de la politique euh africain de la de la
France notamment la PO la politique de
défense de s'attarder davantage sur ce
que font les autres
euh dans dans un article publié par
Mohamed Dib dans les années 90 dans le
monde il parlait de l'Algérie il y avait
cette belle formule qu'on peut appliquer
à la France mais à d'autres pays il dit
les fautifs pour nous les fautifs sont
toujours les autres et les autres vont
du voisin du palier au au fermierers de
l'Oklahoma donc au lieu de passer son
temps à à dire ce que font les autres
que désinformation l'influence il faudra
s'interroger sur les failles et les
insuffisances de sa propre stratégie
parce que si on se met à à à à consacrer
davantage de temps à dire ce que font
les autres ce qu'ils ne font pas euh en
fait on leur donne le temps pour avoir
une une très bonne longueur d'avance en
matière en matière de de de de de
stratégie en matière de réflexion et
donc à s'installer alors qu'on est en
train de de de de réfléchir sur ce
qu'ils font euh dernier dernier dernier
élément qu'il y est lié à ça c'est c'est
une question d'ordre global concernant
aussi euh aussi l'Afrique c'est de
s'interroger sur la puissance
française la moitié de la planète voire
plus sont contre les États-Unis mais
tout le monde compose avec la puissance
américaine alors pourquoi dans d'autres
lieux ses autres cieux on compose pas
avec la la la puissance française donc
il faut interroger ses ses propres
ressorts de ses propres ressources de
puissance à avant de avant d'aller
d'aller voir ce que font font les autres
parfois pour pour dénoncer mais dénoncer
ne fait pas avancer le le débat et
dénoncé ne relève jamais de la réflexion
stratégique je vous
remercie merci beaucoup pour cette
intervention alors mes chers collègu il
nous reste une bonne heure puisque'à 11h
on devra monter en commission des
affaires étrangères pour le l'audition
d'bert Vedrine donc je vous propose si
possible de viser 2 minutes pour vos
interventions et si vous le souhaitez
euh on peut avoir des réponses
immédiates malgré nos trois intervenants
dans ce cas il faudrait que vous dans
votre question que vous puissiez
l'adresser en particulier à un
intervenant euh dans la mesure du du
possible pour le groupe Renaissance la
parole est à Benoît
Borda monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues Mesdames et Messieurs les
intervenants je tenais déjà à exprimer
notre sincère gratitude envers chacun
d'entre vous pour votre présence à cette
table ronde et vos propos utiles dans un
moment euh de réflexion sur les défis de
la démilitarisation tion de la politique
africaine de la
France en tant que PL d'être président
du groupe d'amitié Fran giibouti et
vi-président du groupe d'amitié France
Chad et je suis particulièrement
sensible à la question de la présence
militaire française en
Afrique la remise en question de cette
présence s'inscrit dans un contexte qui
met à l'épreuve la sécurité et la
stabilité du continent certains pays
africains veulent le retrait des tout
françaises tandis que d'autres
maintiennent des bases militaires pour
une coopération stratégique vous l'avez
dit euh tout à l'heure madame Sonia
leourrielc vous avezqué le fait de
regarder à l'Est euh c'était important
et un exemple récent alors avant de de
parler de Djibouti et des intérêts des
accords qui sont qui sont en cours un
exemple récent de cette évolution aussi
sur euh notre regard c'est le retrait
progressif nos forces au nigerre en
octobre de3 provisoirement vers le Tchad
et un autre point à noter euh les
discussions en cours entre les ministres
français et djiboutiens pour réviser le
traité de coopération en en matière de
défense depuis mai 2023 Djibouti du
point de vue géographique et maritime
occupe une place centrale dans la
politique africaine de la France et je
rappelle c'est un pays francophone
entouré de pays anglophone la base
française de Djibouti a récemment
démontré son importance stratégique lors
de l'opération Sagittaire en avril 2023
soulignant la réactivité des forces
françaises face aux crises émergentes
donc mes chers collèg je vous remercie
d'avoir pu éclairer nos travaux mais
effectivement de regarder les choses
dans le globalité et de préciser que
c'est pas on n pas un départ de la
France sur toute l'Afrique mais qu'on a
peut-être des choses à revoir dans No
fonctionnement et je m'inquiète aussi
effectivement au niveau de Djibouti ce
tout petit pays très regardé par les
Chinois par les Américains par tout un
tas de personnes et cet emplacement il
est stratégique pour nous et donc nous
avons besoin de de solidifier nos nos
accords et nos échanges avec ce
pays et donc mon chers collègue vous
avez pas de questions en particulier
peut-être qu'on pourra interroger euh
madame le gourerle sur que vous êtes
très intéressé sur Djibouti sur le
l'état du tcmd à moins qu'on enlève
cette question on va dire voilà sur
l'appréciation finalement de notre
relation avec dibouti où on eston de
manière très très
actuelle je me gardera bien de parler du
traité parce que je pourrais être
détrompé ou démenti demain ou les jours
qui viennent donc je me garderai de
rentrer dans ce dans ce débat notamment
mais je voudrais quand même un aspect un
peu historique et profond dans nos
relations avec Djibouti c'est que on
oublie que c'est notre dernier c'est le
dernier état à avoir obtenu son
indépendance puisqu'ils ont obtenu leur
indépendance en
1977 et que ce soit pendant la
colonisation ou après puisque la France
a maintenu des liens très importants les
diibouiens se sont toujours sentis un
peu délaissés par la France ils ont
toujours estimé qu'on ne les visitait
pas suffisamment ils ont toujours estimé
qu'on était qu'ils étaient un peu la
dernière roue du Carros dans notre
politique et effectivement bah très
souvent quand quand on parle de notre
politique africaine on pense à l'ouest
et il se se sentent toujours un petit
peu mis de côté il il se pose la
question et je tiens à souligner une
chose c'est que
euh il est sûrement très important pour
Djibouti d'être sorti du tête à-tête
avec la France et d'avoir
multilatéralisé ses relations ils sont
peut-être tombés dans un autre tête-
à-tête avec la Chine et l'endettement de
Djibouti à l'égard de la Chine est très
important et à surveiller mais on a un
peu aussi provoqué cette situation je me
permets de le dire ici parce qu'à chaque
fois que les djibouiens sont venus vers
nous pour nous demander il ils
soulignent toujours qu'ils viennent
d'abord vers nous nous demander des
choses donc quand ils ont voulu refaire
leur port ils se sont d'abord tournés
vers les Français et moi ils m'ont dit
dans plusieurs entretiens vous nous avez
un peu riononné donc on s'est tourné
vers les Émirats euh et euh à plusieurs
reprises j'ai entendu ça à chaque fois
qu'on demande aux Français ou qu'on se
tourne vers les Français qui restent un
partenaire privilégié et bien vous nous
vous on est obligé de demander à
d'autres personnes parce que vous Nour
riez au nez et euh et et je crois que on
on le remarque également du fait que euh
la relation ils nous ont souvent accusé
de déloyauté de manque de loyauté euh à
la fois pendant la guerre civile qui a
eu lieu au début des années 90 où ils
ont estimé le régime Issa Somalie sans
rentrer dans les détail a estimé qu'on
on on soutenait trop l'autre camp
ensuite lorsque en 2000 enfin l'affaire
Borel également je vais pas y revenir
oou ça a été ça nos relations ont été
très très tendues et ensuite en 2008
lorsque les éitréens ont attaqué à la
frontière ils ont estimé que nous avons
pas suffisamment euh nous sommes pas
suffisamment intervenus et nous avons
pas fait fonctionner notre accord de
défense alors je je pense qu'ils ont il
y a aussi un mythe jeavais essayer de
développer ça dans des papiers un mythe
à Djibouti euh de la crainte de se faire
vraiment attaquer par leurs voisins et
de perdre leurs souveraineté ça a été le
cas ils sont nés euh enfin l'État
diibouien est né en 1977 avec les deux
pores-avions Français au large pour
protéger le référendum d'indépendance
face aux véléités éthiopiennes et
somaliennes d'envahir le pays donc le
pays s'est construit avec cette vision
que les voisins étaient dangereux que
c'était un ils étaient au cœur du
cyclone et que eux s'étaient stabilisé
mais que ils pouvait être attaqué par
les voisins et ça ça renaît actuellement
avec les propos d'AB Ahmed en Éthiopie
donc faut toujours garder en tête et et
pour les Français Djibouti alors ils
aiment pas trop quand on dit tout petit
tout petit pays mais je je fais partie
des gens qui qui enfin c'est catégorisé
comme un petit État en relation
internationale et pour nous ce qui est
important c'est de voir que ça n'est pas
que Djibouti et son millions d'habitants
et cet accès sur le Golfe
c'est toute l'Afrique de l'Est qui est
derrière c'est le géant éthiopien c'est
le Kenya c'est c'est tout ça qui a aussi
derrière donc cette position elle est
importante aussi pour ça et on a vu
récemment pour l'évacuation qu'on a mené
notamment au au Soudan pour le groupe
rassemblement national la parole est à
Frédéric
bocaletti merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs je vous remercie
pour vos interventions il est un sujet
sur lequel nous devrions tous tomber
d'accord oui la politique africaine de
la France est à revoir intégralement le
chef d'état-major des armées Thierry
Burkard l'a lui-même rappelé dans cette
commission ce constat ne vaut pas que
pour la politique de défense et révision
ne signifie pas retrait précipité ou
abandon total de nos positions et
implantation militairees en Afrique
comment envisager que nos troupes
françaises qui luttent contre le
terrorisme à forcerie islamiste se
désengage alors que ce combat est encore
inachevé certes l'intervention militaire
n'est pas la seule réponse viable au
terrorisme elle n'en reste pas moins
nécessaire on ne combat pas des
fanatiques violents par la parole
comment ne pas considérer cette
perspective de désarmement comme un
affaiblissement de la puissance de la
France sur le continent ce serait
d'autant moins compréhensible que
d'autres puissances comme les États-Unis
maintiennent leur position et que des
compétiteurs comme la
Russie privent pas de maximiser leurs
intérêts en Afrique nous ne devons pas
oublier que si la France est intervenue
au Mali en 2013 c'est à la demande des
autorités alienne et que le rôle qu'elle
a joué dans ce contexte a été largement
reconnu par la communauté internationale
nous ne devons pas non plus oublier tous
les militaires français qui sont morts
sur le sol africain leur sacrifice ne
doit pas rester vain dans la lutte que
nous menons sur le ces territoires dans
le seul objectif de maintenir un
équilibre de paix nécessaire pour les
populations locales enfin nous devons
penser à nos ressortissants qui vivent
et travaillent sur le continent la
France de leur doit leur apporter
protection et le soutien qu'il mérite
l'effacement de l'armée française du
continent africain n'est pas souhaitable
pour de nombreux pays africains et pour
la France elle-même beaucoup de choses
restent cependant à changer dans notre
politique africaine néanmoins nous ne
pouvons pas envisager une disation pure
et simple du territoire africain les
comportements vis-à-vis des populations
et autorités doivent-elles être
remodelées afin de satisfaire VX
exigences diplomatiques équitables je
vous
remercie merci alors à qui s'adresse
votre question chers collègues est-ce
que vous avez une zone en particulier
qui vous intéresse Afrique de l'Ouest
qui souhait répondre
alors je vous en prie alors ça peut être
aussi bien l'Afrique de l'Ouest que la
partie du du Maghreb je vous souhaitais
répondre je vous en prie
oui les les les les questions que vous
soulevez sont sont
réelles il y a il y a à la fois un rejet
français mais il y a aussi une demande
de de de France c'est c'est c'est ce
qu'il faut avoir en
tête évidemment dans les pays séliens on
a vu ce qui s'est passé ces dernières
ces dernières années mais on a
parallèlement des pays euh qui sont en
demande je pense notamment au Bénin qui
qui plutôt en demande de coopération
avec la France sur sur le le le le foyer
djihadiste dont dont je vous parlais
tout à l'heure dans dans ma présentation
euh j'insisterai je vais je vais
rebondir sur ce que disait Sonia
logourelec dans sa présentation et dans
dans sa sa première son autre
intervention euh je crois moi la notion
de politique africaine m'a toujours
rissé à à titre à titre personnel parce
qu'on parle pas de politique américaine
ou de politique asiatique de la France
on a des des des régions avec des
dynamiques ext extrêmement différentes
on peut
voir les différences qui ont été
évoquées entre l'Afrique de l'Est et on
n' pas le même passé on n pas les même
relation
euh donc il faut avoir ça en tête un
autre élément qu'il faut avoir ir en
tête et ça a été aussi évoqué
précédemment c'est que nos intérêts
économiques ont
considérablement évoluer
géographiquement sur le
continent depuis les
indépendances de
mémoire l'Afrique le continent africain
représente à peu près 5,3 % de nos
échanges commerciaux ce qui est
important
euh les zones Fran FAA parce que il y en
a plusieurs évidemment représentent 0 6
% de notre commerce
extérieur et vous imaginez que le le
premier partenaire subsaharien
francophone dans nos échanges bilatéraux
c'est la Côte d'Ivoire qui n'apparaît
qu'à la 8e ou 9e place pendant pendant
ces enfin ces dernières années alors ça
veut pas dire qu'on doit abandonner et
qu'on doit partir des pays francophones
militairement économiquement mais
prendre conscience que la France a des
liens
économiques et et commerciaux très
puissants avec l'ensemble du continent
et ses premiers partenaires sont pas
sont pas francophones ils sont sont les
deux plus grandes économies du du du de
l'Afrique sub-saharienne le le l'Angola
et le parle pardon la République
sud-africaine et le et le nigéa l'Angola
est aussi un partenaire un partenaire
important donc il faut avoir tout ça en
tête quand on veut remettre en en place
une
non pas une mais des politiques
africaines et là encore il y a il y a à
la fois un rejet de la France mais il y
a aussi une une demande de de France sur
les questions sécuritaires comme sur les
autres questions donc c'est pour ça
qu'il faut qu'il faut réfléchir de
manière
différenciée très bien merci pour le
groupe Lain France insoumise la parole
est à Aurélien
saintoule merci monsieur le président
madame messieurs merci beaucoup de V de
vos
interventions comme d'habitude je me
garderai de faire une intervention son
trop générale et j'iraai directement
vers les questions puisque nous
partageons en fait l'essentiel du du
diagnostic le dilemme qui existe entre
la responsabilité à intervenir et le
souci de ne pas tomber dans le
néocolonialisme la vision vous avez
d'une certaine mauvaise foi qui
existerait dans les discours
néosouverainiste et en même temps la
nécessité de s'interroger sur les
objectifs la réalité des ressources les
les les intérêts et la réalité des
ressources de la France et enfin la
question du double standard qui existe
bien effectivement puisque dans le cas
de J outil il est classé 137e pays sur
167 à l'index des démocraties dans le
cas du Tchad 160e carrément sur 167 ou
encore le soutien de la France aux
Émirats arabes unis à l'Arabie Saoudite
dans leur guerre au Yémen
particulièrement cruelle et et criminel
qui probablement explique aussi une
partie du de l'hostilité que les outils
peuvent avoir à notre égard ceci étant
posé trois questions très précises quels
sont les circuits financiers aujourd'hui
qui permettent qui font vivre euh le le
Sahel puisque cet espèce d'effondrement
des États ne va pas forcément avec une
disparition de l'argent euh que d'une
certaine façon on vit aujourd'hui au
Sahel à peu près ce qu'on a vécu en
Afghanistan que des groupes sont en
train de se substituer à l'État il y a
pas un Nans land dans cette zone donc
cette question à mon avis est très
le somalland question très précise mais
parce que il me semble que ça peut être
un un exemple emblématique du fait que
la noninvention produit parfois ou
souvent ou peut-être euh des fruits plus
intéressants que l'intervention
systématique même si elle nous laisse
dans une forme d'expectatives qui est
difficile à admettre et puis la
troisième question porte sur la la
réalité des intérêts qui sont liés euh
tout simplement aux intérêts de
population nous avons énormément de
binationaux ou de communautés françaises
présentes dans de nombreux pays en
particulier au Maghreb comment on peut
s'appuyer comment on peut mobiliser ces
communautés pour avoir une politique
plus
respectueuse très bien merci alors si je
comprends bien il y a une question pour
chaque des intervenants alors
normalement le budget temps pour
répondre c'est 2 minutes donc je vous
propose de chacun faire une réponse
assez courte je pense que vous êtes
capable autour de d'une minutes ou un
peu plus donc on peut commencer par les
circuits financiers du du Sael avec
àanti alors dans votre question je il y
avait un
aspect disons financement des États ou
des ou plutôt des des des groupes je
vais répondre sur les sur sur les
groupes armés djihadistes bon les
circuits financiers ils sont ils sont
connus c'est que les groupes djihadistes
instore une une espèce de de de d'impôt
sur les populations et vivent aussi sur
la taxation des des circulations de
marchandises notamment ils sont très
présents autour des des zones auriifères
quand quand il y en a et il il taxent
les circulations de marchandises licite
ou ou non licite donc contrairement à ce
qui a été beaucoup affirmé on a on a
beaucoup fantasmé sur des sur des parins
du djihadisme saélien qui verseraiit de
l'argent des des choses comme ça toutes
les données qui remontent du terrain
témoignent que c'est ce sont ces ils
sont branchés sur ces circuits là voilà
très bien merci pour la briité de la
réponse maintenant pour le Somaliland et
est-ce que c'est un bon exemple de
l'apport d'e non intervention enfin de
si j'ai bien compris la question 2
minutes
euh une minute oui euh et en plus je
vais juste me permettre de reprendre
pour le Sael ce que disait un collègue
Jean-François Bayard il y a quelques
années qui dis disait que cet espace
c'est l'interstice des systèmes
internationals des états zonees
mouvantes où il y a plus vraiment d'État
al voilà je trouvais que l'expression
était intéressante somalyland donc état
non reconnu au niveau international
puisque je vous rappelle que la
reconnaissance se fait en bilatéral et
si de façon informelle on pourrait on
travailler avec eux ou les nombreux
États de la région travailler avec eux
il est évident que ça n'est pas les pays
occidentaux qui vont reconnaître le
somaland que c'est aux voisins de le
faire et que la Somalie ne le veut pas
mais effectivement on a un contreexemple
de développement de l'État et on pourra
en discuter après entre ce qui s'est
fait au somalylande sans intervention
étrangère pays le moins endetté du
continent africain puisqu'on ne peut pas
lui prêter d'argent et certains le le le
présentent comme le secret le me garder
du continent africain et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que dans sa
construction le somalilland a su
mélanger à la fois euh des des attributs
de l'État tels qu'on les connaît comme
on le connaît en Europe tel qu'il s'est
construit en Europe et avec également de
la justice traditionnelle et des des
modes de régulation traditionnel et ce
mélange semble avoir plutôt bien
fonctionné même si vous auraz pas
échaqué que ces derniers mois il a aussi
des conflits à l'Est mais voilà ça a
tout d'un état ils ont leur armée leurs
élections et cetera et il n'y a jamais
eu d'intervention effectivement et ce
qui est le contre mododèle parfait du
laboratoire des intervention étrangère
qui'est la Somalie mais ça c'est un
autre débat merci enfin une dernière
question peut-être qui concerne plus le
Maghreb si j'ai bien compris sur le rôle
des diaspora dans la relation avec Les
Afriques alors très rapidement je pense
pas que ça puisse ça puisse fonctionner
pour pour diverses raisons euh d'abord
je je pense qu'il est très difficile de
réformer un système à la marge j'ouvreis
une parenthèse l'Union européenne dans
ses relations avec les pays africains
parfois euh des sociétés non
démocratiques des systèmes autoritaires
elle parle de la réforme de la justice
qui est à l'ordre du système autoritaire
donc il est très difficile de de de
réformer si vous voulez euh un système
relationnel à à la marge en ant de de
s'appuyer sur la la société civile
elle-même tributaire du bonvau volloir
de du pouvoir politique de part et
d'autre de la Méditerranée deuxième
chose la communauté j'allais dire des
binationaux qui l'a plus à même de de
d'agir dans ce sens-là et et dans une
situation très inconfortable sur la rive
sud est pas ils ne sont plus euh tout à
fait nationaux et sur la rive sud ils
sont pas assez nationaux et donc ils
sont en fait de vrais méditerranéens ils
sont ni sur la rive nord ni sur laarive
Sud mais en haute mer donc le le
dépasser les blocages politiques les
blocages institutionnels par le biais de
la société civile ça restera toujours
marginal il n'affectera pas me
semble-t-il le le modèle
relationnel euromagrébin en général
merci très bien merci pour le groupe les
républicains la parole est à Nathalie
ser merci monsieur le Président madamees
messieurs merci pour vos propos
liminires alors je vais avoir une
question pour chacun voilà euh monsieur
antil vous avez dit qu'il y avait une
grande difficulté pour pour la France de
lire la vision de nos partenaires
saéliens euh al c'est une question qui
est large pourquoi on a des S tank on a
de nombreux chercheurs et malgré tout on
n arrive pas ne serait-ce pas lié au
fait que en fait c'est jamais les mêmes
nos interlocuteurs saéliens
euh pour vous Madame euh vous avez parlé
du du projet qu'il fallait qu'onorte une
vision et que le projet indoppacifique
pouvait en être un et euh pour être allé
au Gabon il y a pas longtemps ils
viennent de signer avec le Commons donc
je voilà comment comment nous on
s'insère dans ce dans ce processus là
puisque visiblement enfin nos
partenaires se tournent vers d'autres
d'autres formes de autres que la France
et pour vous monsieur Benantar je vous
dites il faut interroger nos propres
ressorts de puissance donc du point de
vue du Magreb selon vous quels sont-ils
les ressorts de puissance de la
France Merci al vous avez la
parole al moi je dirais que le il y a
dans dans la recherche pas seulement
dans les S tank il y a y a beaucoup de
chercheurs qui travaillent sur le Sahel
et à l'intérieur des des des des
ministères il y a aussi beaucoup
d'analyes qui ont pointé euh les choses
que je pointais tout à l'heure et et ça
assez tôt la question qui se pose c'est
pourquoi ça n'a pas impacté les les les
décisions donc ça ça c'est la c'est
c'est la question c'est pas la question
de de de la rotation de de nos
partenaires le deuxième le deuxième
aspect c'est que et ça on a du mal de le
comprendre en France nos partenaires
nous connaissent beaucoup mieux que nous
nous les connaissons il a une asymétrie
de connaissance qui est très très forte
ils parlent notre langue ils ont étudié
dans nos
universités ils ont une connaissance
intime de nos débats politique y compris
intérieur l'inverse n'est pas vrai et et
ils ont ils sont effectivement plus
faibles sécuritairement politiquement
économiquement que que nous mais ils
savent travailler la le le la la
relation du faible au
fort merci Madame pour la réveréron
concernant donc le les nouveaux
partenariats possibles oui alors quand
vous avez évoqué le Gabon ça me permet
de dire qu'effectivement il faut pas
qu'on oublie l'Afrique centrale côtière
on pourra peut-être y revenir à d'autres
moments mais oui nous ne sommes plus
seuls sur le continent africain et oui
il y a des concurrents et nos
partenaires peuvent jouer de ces
concurrences et d'aller vers le le plus
haut Fran et cetera c'est tout le c'est
tout le le le l'enjeu et le défi
aujourd'hui tout à fait euh et je pense
je je veux insister sur ce qu'a dit à
laantille il y a un vrai problème me
semble-t-il de en France aujourd'hui de
méconnaissance du continent africain ça
se voit à dans tous les domaines euh bah
alors nous ça se voit à l'université
parce qu'il y a très peu d'africanistes
internationalistes même si on on a de
très bons historiens anthropologues et
cetera et cetera euh qui a une forte
méconnaissance parfois aussi dans nos
politiques on reprend souvent les
discours ambiants sur l'Afrique et donc
on nous reproche souvent d'être
paternaliste euh avec nos partenaires
africains ça ça revient beaucoup et je
pense qu'il faudra aussi à un moment
peut-être pas à moi de le faire mais il
faudra interroger et faire un bilan
effectivement de de ce qui s'est passé
en Afrique de l'Ouest et euh l'action le
cadre intellectuel conditionne l'action
donc la formation sur les questions
africaines de nos
et des personnes présentes en Afrique de
l'Ouest doit être aussi attentivement
prise en compte me
semble-t-il très bien et enfin sur les
leviers de puissance français au au
Maghreb de réponse très brièvement
d'abord le le voisinage géographique
c'est c'est un élément important il
compris pour les échanges économiques et
puis ce
ce cette
dire sorte de fond commun historique
culturelle et cetera cette mobilité
humaine qui est qui est toujours dans le
même sens va dans le même sens
d'ailleurs on constate un décoplage
total entre mobilité humaine et
politique les sociétés Sud
méditerranéenes en général continuent
être tourné vers le nord vers la rive
nord et les gouvernements se tournent
davantage vers l'est vers la Chine ou un
peu plus au nord
nord-est vers la Russie donc le le le
les paradigmes changent au plan
politique mais il ne change pas au plan
au plan social et et c'est intéressant à
relever pour voir euh comment ce ce
décalage comment les gouvernements
composent avec euh d'ailleurs de part et
d'autres de la Méditerranée compose avec
avec ce ce ce ce découlage en entre les
deux euh le deuxème point le l'autre
ressort de de de puissance de la France
il est d'ordre politique il est connu
dans dans l'arcane des des des
institutions européennes à Bruxelles que
les trois gouvernements sud-européens
c'est de espagnol italien français mais
aussi portugais 4e sont des les avocats
des gouvernements maghrébains à travers
à travers les négociations donc ça c'est
c'est un levier un levier de de de
puissance qui qui donne à ces pays du
poid euh dans leur dans leur rapport euh
avec leurs partenaires européens mais
aussi mais aussi maghrébens et je
viendrai sur la remarque de de mon
collègue sur les échanges certes ces
pays-là euh euh pour la France
leurs échanges avec la France sont
insignifiants dans le commerce
international de la France mais pour eux
la France est un partenaire important il
y a quelques années maintenant la
structure des échanges a quelque peu
changé les pays l'Union européenne
sacapare environ 60 jusqu'à 70 % dans
certains pays dans le cas de certains
pays maghriébins
euh de leur commerce c'est-à-dire
l'essentiel 2 ti3 de leur commerce se
fait avec l'Union européenne mais il ne
représente que 3 % à peu près du
commerce européen donc c'est
insignifiant pour l'Union européenne
mais c'est stratégique pour eux puisque
la moindre décision de la part de la
part de l'Union européenne peut impacter
leur économie on se souvient de de la
guerre de de la tomate entre entre
l'Union européenne et le Maroc lorsque
l'Union a imposé imposé des quotas au
Maroc ou sur le les poissons enfin sur
la pêche pour pour pour la Mauritanie
euh il il me voilà dernier point c'est
je je me permets de faire cette remarque
mais même si je suis très très mal placé
pour pour la faire devant vous
c'est on mène pas des politiques en
fonction de tempérament changeant de
l'opinion publique et et et des
couvertures médiatiques sinon on sera
amené à à déclarer des guerres aux uns
aux autres tous les jours donc il faut
il faut un cas politique qui qui résiste
un peu au soucouss sismique de l'opinion
publique et des
des des alliens médiatiques voilà je
merci merci pour le groupe démocrate la
parole est à Josie poo merci monsieur le
Président mes chers collègues merci à
nos trois intervenants pour leurs propos
liminires tous aussi intéressant
passionnants et et instructif pour de
chacun d'entre vous si nous évoquons
aujourd'hui les enjeux de la
démilitarisation de la politique
africaine de la France c'est pour
évaluer les alternatives qui se
présentent désormais à nous dans
l'hypothèse d'une démilitarisation dont
l'impact reste à évaluer sérieusement
ces alternatives apparaissent clairement
comme des alternatives politique puisque
la démilitarisation débouche par
définition sur l'exclusion de toute
présence ou action militaire cela
sous-entend donc de se positionner de
dialoguer de s'adresser à de multiples
acteurs que ceci soit institutionnel ou
plus informel je pense notamment à
prendre en compte l'opinion ou plus
exactement aux opinions c'est un réel et
des un réel et ancien défi mais un défi
renouvelé de nos jours nous devons
convaincre pour ma part j'ai souvent
plaidé ici en faveur du renforcement du
3è pilier de notre doctrine 3D
c'est-à-dire défense diplomatie
développement celui du développement
pour que le progrès soit rapide efficace
visible et se manifeste largement en
dehors des grands centres urbains
c'était me semble-t-il une façon directe
de le de faire et de faire savoir mais
la France pour de nombreuses raisons a
toujours éprouvé des difficultés à
communiquer sur sa politique africaine
la communication politique est une force
quand elle appuie des actions concrètes
de terrain alors où on où on en est
aujourd'hui alors où en est aujourd'hui
pardon cette capacité à communiquer
alors que même l'aide publique au
développement fait l'objet de critique
de surcroit dans un environnement
géopolitique où les actions d'influence
et de compétiteurs percutent le réel
monsieur antil vous avez par exemple
analysé les forces à l'œuvre au Sahel
dont le but est de dégrader d'attaquer
l'image de la France l'information
circule très vite en particulier via le
relais des jeunes générations et de la
diaspora nous avons besoin de nous
déployer dans cet espace public selon
vous par qui par quel moyen notre pays
é-il en mesure de tourner la page de la
militarisation pour se concentrer sur le
champ politique et faire ainsi entendre
sa parole pensez-vous que notre réseau
diplomatique est adapté l'armée
doit-elle encore jouer un rôle le moment
ne serait-il pas venu d'abord par
ailleurs les enjeux de défense comme
étant des enjeux transversaux
interministériels ce qui nous interroge
sur les outils d'une analyse commune et
sur l'adaptation de nos moyens
d'intervention tant en France qu'en lien
avec l'Europe d'ailleurs ou plus
largement encore avec les instances
pardon de discussion multilatérale je
vous merci la parole est donc à
alaintil c'est une question complète et
complexe sur sur le je va je je vais
reprend prendre dans le le sens inverse
de de de vos
questions je vais reprendre l'expression
qu'avait qu'avait pris au début de de de
Barc un un diplomate français célèbre
Laurent Bigot il avait dit voilà le
Sahel c'est ces 5000 soldats français
combien de diplomates français en plus
au Sahel depuis C ces crises il y a eu
un déphasage complet il y a eu un
débranchement même pratiquement de la
diplomatie au profit d'une approche
sécuritaire très très forte et et et ça
rebondit avec ce que je vous disais dans
mon dans mon propos
liminire l'incapacité à à à lire
politiquement ce qui se passait vient de
là parce qu'on a des on a des très bons
analystes au sein de de de nos
ministères mais il faut s' se donner les
moyens pour que qu'il ait ces analyses
qui soient qui soi produites donc ça
c'est un un un un premier aspect on peut
intervenir militairement mais il faut
aussi muscler sa sa capacité euh disons
politique d'analyse pour savoir
exactement ce qu'on fait l'impact de ce
qu'on fait comment on est perçu par les
partenaires euh et qu'est-ce qu'on
combat parce que on on pense qu'on
combat le le le terrorisme international
alors que toutes les études qu'on a sur
le le le Sahel nous montrent que c'est
beaucoup plus complexe que ça ce sont
des ressorts euh parfois très locaux euh
sur lequel on n' pas forcément quelque
chose à dire ou à apporter euh il y a il
y a il y a dans certains certaines zones
des des règlements de compte entre
communautés des règlements de compte au
sein de certaines communautés entre des
couches anciennement serviles et leurs
anciens maîtres je suis pas sûr que
c'est à la France de venir appuyer le
Mali pour régler des des problèmes de
cette de cette nature donc ça il faut
quand on envisage d'intervenir
militairement quelque part il faut se
muscler euh diplomatiquement ou en tout
cas
être en capacité de de de connaître les
tenants et les aboutissants véritable
sinon on risque de se faire
instrumentaliser d'où ma remarque de
tout à l'heure sur la symétrie de
connaissance ça veut dire que les nos
partenaires ils sont beaucoup plus
faibles que nous mais ils nous
connaissent beaucoup mieux ils peuvent
ils peuvent aussi nous nous nous
manipuler alors le développement
évidemment dans l'idéal le développement
mais il faut apporter un bémol à cette à
cette vision parce que souvent on a
l'impression que le développement et la
et et la petite baquette magique qui va
tout changer euh et là je vais élargir
le propos à toute opération de de de
développement et pas simplement à l'aide
française
euh il faut s'interroger sur l'impact du
du développement sur le développement
des des pays le développement est un
terme général qui recouvre beaucoup de
choses il y a des choses qui
fonctionnent très très bien des
formation il y a de il y a tout un tas
de de de de choses mais il y a aussi des
choses qui fonctionnent très mal mal et
des et du développement des flux
d'argent liés au développement qui ont
alimenté les
problèmes donc il faut avoir ça en tête
le le
le vouloir substituer le développement à
la à la au diplomatique ou au politique
euh il faut pas penser que c'est la
solution miracle et que c'est la la pire
philosophale
euh l'aide publique au développement il
faut la comprendre politiquement c'est
une c'est une c'est c'est un des aspects
de la politique étrangère française
comme de celle des nombreux partenaires
africains maintenant des pays du Gol des
pays asiatiques de pays certains pays
latino-américains de pays européens qui
n'ont pas de tradition africaine on est
un parmi tant d'autres euh il m'a pas
euh il m'a enfin il est pas frappant que
l'aide publique au développement
fonctionne mieux dans dans d'autres pays
que que que dans que dans le nôre donc
il faut évidemment il faut continuer le
l' public au développement il y a tout
un tas de choses qui fonctionnent bien
mais d'une part dans des pays où le les
questions de sur de question de sécurité
se pose avec avec beaucoup de de
d'acuité bah la question qu'est-ce
comment on peut faire du développement
dans des pays où on peut pas déployer
des projets de développement
euh faire du faire du développement
aujourd'hui au Burkina Faso au Mali
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire c'est c'est
donc vous voyez le j'ai répondu un peu
en tout tournant autour de vos questions
mais ça ça nous donne une quand même une
une ambiance et une une perplexité
euh voilà merci est-ce que vous
souhaitez apporter un complément de
réponse sur ces sujets de développement
je vous en prie Monsieur ben juste
ajouter ajouter un point à ce qui a été
dit sur le le prisme terroriste ça c'est
c'est c'est le risque majeur auquel
auquel font face les différents acteurs
qu'il soient démocratique ou pas les
gouvernements agissent tous de la même
manière plus ou moins de la même manière
face face au
terrorisme l'une des problématiques au
sa effectivement c'est ce prisme
terroriste qui fait que on le le fait de
brandir le terrorisme ça fait taire tout
le monde parce que ça fait peur à tout
le monde cont tenu des des risques
encourus encouru à la fois pour les les
citoyens mais pour pour pour les états
et en relation international par concept
de sécuritisation c'est-à-dire que le
processus performatif hein c'est vous
savez le le langage juridique est par
excellence performatif à travers lequel
lequel un phénomène ou une question ne
relevant pas de la sécurité devienne une
question de sécurité c'est ainsi que par
le BIA du terrorisme la question Awa au
nordmi est devenu un problème un
problème terroriste mais on règle pas ce
type de problème par par par par la la
voie militaire quoi qu'il arrive c'est
ce prisme terroriste conduit à l'urgence
à l'urgence sécuritaire qui renvoie en
fait les États du Nord comme du Sud à
leur propre échec c'est-à-dire que au
lieu au lieu euh au lieu d'agir en amant
ils attendent pour réagir en aval et
donc infini si vous voulez la
militarisation de la lutte
antiterroriste est en soit un échec
politique puisqu'on n' pas réussi à à
traiter le problème à à sa source et
donc là m'amène à d'autres à d'autres
régions à d'autres conflits on
s'accommode des conflits gelés en
estimant que dès lors que ça ne déborde
pas ça ne pose pas de problème de
sécurité c'est c'est pas grave mais
lorsque ça éclate aussi bien le
processus que la structure du conflit
vous échappe et donc ça vous demande
beaucoup plus d'argent et beaucoup plus
d'énergie et là comme par miracle
lorsqu'il y a urgence sécuritaire il y a
beaucoup d'argent la France a
mobilisé la communauté dit
internationale pour pour pour lever des
fonds pour la la force G5 sal mais la mê
aucune initiative de la même taille du
même
volume na été mise en place pour les
aspects économiques donc on trouve de
l'argent pour réprimer ou pour utiliser
les armées les forces de sécurité mais
on n'en trouve pas pour pour développer
ces pays donc l'urgence l'urgence
sécuritaire en fait faosse toute la
politique même avec les les meilleures
intentions le dernier point concernant
le Sahel c'est euh
euh on n'agit pas et donc on réagit et
lorsqu'on réagit on réagit souvent mal
pourquoi euh parce que c'est ce sont des
stratégie concurrentielle des États qui
sont impliqués dans des des enjeux de de
des jeux de de rivalité et on se
retrouve avec une sorte d'inflation ça a
été démontré par un certain nombre de
travaux où les pays sailiens n'avaient
pas les capacité d'absorber toute
l'aide qu'il recevait et à tel point que
la la bureaucratisation de du LED pose
des problèmes sécuritaires il y avait un
militaire malien me semble était
burkinabi citit par par un un travail
universitaire qui disait que on on on on
est tellement appelé à assister à des
réunions en Europe notamment enfin c'est
quelqu'un qui qui qui fait la remarque
il dit n militaires sont tellement
sollicités par assist à des réunions
qu'ils passent leur temps dans les
salons dans les réunions que que de que
sur le terrain pour combattre le le
terrorisme je vous remercie merci pour
le groupe socialiste la parole est à
Isabelle
Santiago avec le micro si
possible merci monsieur le président
chers
collègues merci à vous trois vous dire
tout d'abord que c'était je suis arrivé
un peu retard donc je je m'excuse
puisque je n'ai pas pu entendre l'un des
des des des auditeurs et des de
l'orateur par contre vous dire que
vraiment pour les propos que j'ai pu
entendre tout d'abord je partage
évidemment le fond je trouve que c'est
dans ce cycle Afrique ça nous permet
aussi en commission de la défense
d'approfondir le le fond et je crois que
c'est en tout cas essentiel et ça
participe à à notre réflexion donc je je
vous en remercie et je voulais aborder
une question qui me m'intéresse à savoir
vous en avez pas mal de choses au au fur
et à mesure du temps qui a été évoqué
mais l'actualité qui est accélératrice
et qui a pris donc dans le Sahel ou
l'Afrique occidentale la forme de rejet
de la France comme partenaire milit
économique mais aussi diplomatique comme
on l'a vu cependant il reste ni constant
dans le temps ni uniforme puisque sur
les 54 pays du continent le tissu la
diversité est beaucoup plus complexe
dans le champ des relations
interétatiques donc moi je voulais
aborder en fait la mission
Atalanta qui anciennement force navale
européenne et donc j'ai trouvé que
c'était pour avoir y compris avoir été à
Djibouti je trouve que c'est un bon
exemple de la coopération qui avait été
lancée à l'initiative de la France mais
qui est une coopération qui était
intervention certes militaire mais
commune avec les pays européens prolongé
durant tout un temps assez long pour
lutter contre la la piraterie qui est
dans la Corne de l'Afrique vous l'aviez
dit tout à l'heure un élément
extrêmement important y compris du
commerce mondial et international mais
qui a donné des je trouvais de très bons
résultat et le fait que ce soit aussi à
fort impact au côté des pays qui sont
concernés donc dans cette corne de
l'Afrique et je me demandais si en fait
à travers cette opération et donc cet
esprit de coopération européenne à ce
moment où il y a des sphères d'influence
qui sont évidemment on le sait très
fortte contre la France est-ce que ces
coopérations européennes qui sont faites
comme l'exemple qui a été fait du côté
de Djibouti et en tout cas dans cette
opéra
plus précisément est-ce que ce sont des
modèles sur lequel nous pouvons
poursuivre et en tout cas la France
devrait face à des compétiteurs très
desinhibés pouvoir travailler des
projets avec des
multiartenaires et particulièrement
l'Europe qui doit avoir toute sa place
Al merci pour cette question al qui
concerne l'opération Atalante donc
d'avantage au large de de Djibouti mais
peut-être que les autres pouront
également répondre sur la pertinence
effectivement des opérations
multinational et notamment européenne
donc Sonia Gor vous avez la parole
oui c'est vrai que c'était l'une des
stratégies aussi de la France
d'européaniser sa
présence on parle très peu en en France
de du gros projet global Gateway de
l'Union européenne qui est un peu la
réponse européenne à la belt Road
initiative chinoise et et pourtant en
France c'est très peu médiatisé et et
ben c'est sûrement quelque chose sur
lequel on doit aussi s'appuyer de
construction d'infrastructure et ce et
cetera sur le continent africain
l'éducation le numérique donc ça je
pense que c'est c'est vraiment très
important et euh effectivement il y a eu
il y a tat lante en Afrique de l'Est
l'Union européenne est très présente et
beaucoup de pays européens sont très
présents en Afrique de l'Est et alors je
je c'est la prospective mais j'imagine
que si les attaques de
outil/ash Iran se poursuivent dans la
zone il va falloir sécuriser voir
escorter les navires une nouvelle fois
non pas contre les pirates cette fois
mais contre cette guerre de cour et
j'imagine que ce sera sûrement une
coalition qui va être montée donc
peut-être avec les Américains avec les
Européens aussi et tout le monde va
revenir dans la Corne de l'Afrique je
vous rappelle que si Djibouti a autant
le vent en poupe auprès de tout le monde
c'est qu'ils ont le régime alors ils
aiment pas que je dise le régime le
gouvernement diibousien à profité aussi
des évolutions du système international
à la fois avec la guerre contre le
terrorisme début des années 2000 les
Américains ont installé leur seule base
sur le continent à Djibouti ensuite la
piraterie ça a été un pôle effectivement
de lutte contre la piraterie avec la
présence japonaise européenne et cetera
ensuite la guerre au Yémen qui fait que
les Émirats se sont beaucoup réinvestis
dans la région alors plutôt du côté de
l'éritrée pour mener cette guerre et
ensuite la belle d'Our d'initiative qui
fait que les Chinois se sont réinvestis
donc j'imagine que ce qui est en train
de se passer bon là c'est assez nouveau
hein c'est les derniers jours les
dernières semaines avec cette guerre de
cours qui qui est en train de s'ouvrir
euh va remettre la focale encore une
fois sur de nouvelles opérations à mener
dans la région dans la zone puisque je
crois que c'est près de 20000 navires
qui passent dans le Babel mandb et sur
la mer Rouge donc c'est vraiment on perd
de semaines hein si on qu' tourne euh si
on contend de la mer Rouge donc ça va
être vraiment important de sécuriser la
zone et
euh c'est une nouvelle opportunité pour
les états parfois autoritaires de la
région de ce se rendre indispensable
pour les occidentaux et donc on rappelle
l'opération Atalante c'était des
attaques menées depuis la Somalie
notamment de pirates qui partaient en
speedbat en bateau très rapide et aller
chercher du butin qui les ramené sur les
côtes somaliennes je crois qu'il y avait
eu plus de 150 attaqu à l'époque et que
cette opération avait permis assez
rapidement de de neutraliser enfin
d'escorter d'une certaine manière les
navires notamment commerciaux et à
partir de 2016 il y avait quasiment plus
de plus d'attaque et ça n'était pas que
l'opé puisque en fait le problème était
à terre c'était l'évolution de l'état
somalien à terre et une fois que vous
avez aussi la transition politique qui
s'est enclenché en 2012 avec l'élection
d'un président en Somalie des
changements également au punland ça a
permis de modifier beaucoup de choses
mais on est dans une région vous avez le
pland qui est qui s'autoproclame enfin
qui qui est autonome et le Somaliland
qui n'est pas reconnu donc c'est
difficile de discuter avec eux ou de
d'organiser la lutte à terre très bien
sur les opérations multinationales
oui il y a plein de de choses qui se
passent moi j'ai un j'ai l'exemple avec
l'arrivée de la la cocaïne en Afrique de
l'Ouest à la fin des années des années
2000 et bien alors c'est très peu connu
mais il y a des la plupart des saisis en
mer ont été réalisé par des par des
Européens euh donc la la coopération
sécuritaire avec les pays d'Afrique de
l'Ouest fonctionne la France y a pris sa
part comme comme d'autres pays européens
he et ça c'est c'est évidemment moins
médiatisé que que que Barkan mais il y a
il y a plein de choses qui se passent au
niveau de la formation du renseignement
de de de de de de l'appui aérien de la
surveillance du domaine aérien et je
crois que dans la dans la réflexion sur
les nouvelles positions et et et
postures militaires françaises sur sur
le continent c'est pas non plus sombrer
dans la dans la dans la dépression
complète et se dire a il y a toujours
une demande et il y a aussi des des des
des des des collaborations qui peuvent
être moins implicantes politiquement
pour le pour le partenaire français
c'est beaucoup moins visible beaucoup
moins et c'est beaucoup plus ponctuel
Barkan est une exception dans tout ça
c'est la dernière fois on a mobilisé
plusieurs milliers d'hommes pendant
plusieurs années en Afrique c'est c'est
c'est ça remonte à très très longtemps
et je pense qu'on on lit la la la
présence militaire française à travers
barkane et on a a tort de le faire parce
que c'est un aspect parmi
d'autres monsieur benona vous souhaitez
intervenir sur les coopérations
multinationonal euh je je voulais aller
dans le sens de ma collègue concernant
le le l'instrumentalisation par les
acteurs locaux de cette coopération
internationale puisqu'ils jouent aussi
leur leur propre leur propre partition
elle a cité l'exemple de l'Éthiopie mais
il y a aussi le Tchad qui sont dans
leurs forces sont dans C situations de
surengagement à tel point que ça pose un
problème de de de pour ces ces forces
armées impliquées dans des des
opérations de maintien de la paix donc
il s'agit là pour reprendre l'expression
de Jean-François Bayard de de de
stratégie de d'extraversion il ils se
mettent dans une position de dépendance
stratégique pour tirer profit pour leurs
propres intérêts pour péréniser leur
propres régime donc les opérations
internationales conduisent parfois à la
consolidation de l'autoritarisme en
Afrique euh ou ailleurs d'ailleurs 2uxè
point c'est euh je disais tout à l'heure
que l'Afrique est traversé par par par
par des mutations en profondeur et ça
conduit à des débats sur sur le maintien
de la paix puisque l'essentiel des
opérations en usien de maintien de la
paix sont en Afrique il y a tout un
débat sur les partisans de
l'africanisation et les partisons de
l'appropriation l'africanisation c'est
impliqué davantage les contingents
africains dans des opérations de
maintien de de la paix financé par par
les Nations Unies et d'ailleurs pourquoi
il surant engagement puisque la règle
aux Nations Unies lorsqu'on rembourse
les États ayant des contingents de
maintien de la paix on rembourse d'abord
d'abord les états pauvres donc pour eux
c'est une ressource financière
importante donc les partisans de
l'africanisation c'est juste on envoie
des troupes africaines au lieu de
troupes étrangère ou occidental et ceux
qui qui militent pour l'appropriation
ils veulent non seulement des
contingents africains mais un contrôle
africain du dérouler des opérations donc
là il s'agit de du leadership et et
c'est pas un hasard c'est les trois pays
qui défendent le plus l'appropriation
sont l'Afrique du Sud le Nigéria et et
l'Algérie mais cette appropriation va
évidemment à l'encontre des États qui
qui pratiquent une stratégie de
d'extraversion donc les opérations
multinationales internation sont
importantes mais elles ont des des des
effets pervers importants aussi voilà
merci très bien merci et je précise que
le 17 janvier il y aura sans doute une
audition dédiée au rôle sécuritaire à la
fois de des nations- Unies avec les
opérations de maintien de la paix de de
l'Un l'Union européenne pendant que
d'ailleurs qu'une délégation de la
commission sera au Nigéria et en
Éthiopie pour le groupe horizon la
parole est à Yannick favenek
beé merci Monsieur le le président ma
question s'adresse à Madame le le
gourielc je vais revenir sur Djibouti
dont vous avez à juste titre rappelé
l'importance stratégique pour la France
tout en disant qu'effectivement rien
n'est acquis compte tenu de son
environnement politique et que nous
devons y prêter une meilleure attention
la France et et l'armée française on ont
tout intérêt à entretenir cette amitié
cette coopération en appuyant la montée
en puissance de l'armée dipousienne en
en revoyant à la hausse l'aide publique
au développement sous peine de voir
d'autres puissances prendre le relais la
nature vous l'avez aussi dit ayant
horreur du vide la renégociation du
traité doit par conséquent être j'allais
dire gagnant gagnant et doit être
valorisé à juste titre le monde change
vous l'avez également souligné en
particulier dans cette partie de
l'Afrique Djibouti change j'ai pu men
rendre compte à titre personnel et c'est
pourquoi notre coopération doit évoluer
dans le sens d'un équilibre et de plus
de considération envers cet allié fidèle
alors je ne sais pas si vous pourrez
répondre à cette question mais comment
imaginez-vous l'évolution de notre
accord avec la République djibouienne et
selon vous quel serait un bon
accord madame le
gorelc c'est une question très
compliquée oui surtout que d'autres se
penchent dessus depuis 2 ans
euh vous pouvez revenir de manière plus
générale sur finalement que contiennent
ce type
d'accord à quoi servent-il voilà au-delà
du du sujet d'actualité de de très
grande actualité si vous pouvez pas
répondre précisément sur sur l'actualité
euh quand je faisais parfois des
entretiens avec des dibousiens euh une
des remarques qui m'avait été fait par
parce que je disais toujours qu'il y
avait pas d'ouvrage ou très peu
d'ouvrage ou de recherche sur Djibouti
euh vous devez savoir que vous vous
allez facilement à Djibouti mais pour
les chercheur c'est pas toujours très
facile d'aller à Djibouti il faut bien
le garder en tête et un djiboutien
m'avait répondu vivons heureux vivons
cachés et je pense que peut-être parfois
euh lorsque vous dites que Djibouti est
un allié fidèle mais qui nous a aussi
reproché parfois des manques de loyauté
comme je l'expliquais
euh c'est un allié fidèle mais euh qui
peut aussi on peut aussi nous accuser
parfois de double standard et ça c'est
le rôle he des des politiques c'est
votre rôle c'est qu'à la fois on doit
défendre des intérêts avoir une
politique et notamment en Afrique de
l'Est comme je l'ai dit et dans le même
temps euh dans les intérêts français il
y a les valeurs des droits de l'homme
euh de la démocratie et euh face à des
nouveaux euh euh pardon à des acteurs
internationaux de plus en plus présents
comme la Russie et la Chine qui ne sont
pas des alliés de la France nous devons
sûrement euh garder ses valeurs et les
porter hautes et c'est parfois difficile
quand on a des intérêts voilà sur le
terrain et dans des pays qui sont des
régimes
euh très mal classés sur la liste des
État démocratique ils vous répondront
qu'ils sont sur le chemin de la
démocratie mais on doit aussi entendre
que ce soit au Tchad ou à Djibouti les
les voix des personnes qui peuvent
s'opposer à ce type de
fonctionnement et de gouvernance vous
sentez mes hésitations parce que je sais
qu'on est filmé que c'est pas forcément
évident de parler de ces sujets euh donc
je pense que une un des points qui a été
soulevé par beaucoup de gens ça été la
il y a une enfin une partie sur la
sécurité la défense sécuritaire de
Djibouti mais en interne et je pense que
ça c'était l'un des des clauses qui
restaient et qu'on avait une des seules
clause qui restait sur le continent
africain avec Djibouti sur ce point
j'imagine que les djiboutiens ont
insisté pour Gard ger cette clause
peut-être que c'est une clause qui
aurait pu
euh qui qui peut et qui va peut-être
partir donc ça ça me paraî être un point
important et je pense aussi une chose
qui nous était reprochée c'est que les
chinois sont arrivés ont construit
beaucoup d'infrastructure le pays comme
vous l'avez dit a beaucoup changé et
effectivement nous on a été là pendant
40 ans voire avant l'indépendance et on
voit le pays bah même physiquement les
infrastructures beaucoup de choses
n'avaient pas beaucoup bougé et
peut-être qu'on aurait pu faire plus la
essus euh pour permettre à la fois cet
allié fidèle mais penser aussi à la
population djibouienne et participer au
développement des infrastructure de
l'éducation et cetera dans le pays il y
a des questions sanitaires aussi très
fortes avec le 4at que vous avez
sûrement vous avez sûrement entendu
parler donc qui est une plante
ophorisante qui qui impacte beaucoup
l'économie djiboutienne donc je pense
que peut-être nous aurions dû ne pas
faire que militariser comme l'ont dit
mes collègues et d'avoir une approche
plus globale avec Djibouti à la fin à
fin afin de ménager à la fois notre
partenaire fidèle et aussi les
populations et donc pour en profiter
pour faire un petit focus
sur le contenu de de notre coopération
de défense on peut dire que finalement
ce qu'on la question qui peut se poser
ici c'est à quoi sert cette base de de
Djibouti et finalement dans les grands
axes c'est appuyer les opérations
françaises et notammentpr de l'opération
Sagittaire le rement des bateaux c'est
faire de la coopération avec l'État
djiboutien ou au niveau régional je
crois que notamment mes des collègues en
savent plus que moi ici c'est nous qui
assurons la police du ciel à Djibouti il
y a tout le volet également des actions
civilesou militaires qu'on peut faire
sur place et puis peut-être un dernier
point c'est tout ce qui est
aguérissement de nos forces on a un
complexe d'entraînement à Djibouti qui
est quand même assez exceptionnel et à
la fois terrière mer pour mener des des
manœuvres interarmées ça participe
grandement à aux capacités
opérationnelles de de nos armées voilà
pour donner un une vision un peu globale
de de notre coopération de défense avec
Djibouti mais peut-être que désormais
notre collègue Jean-Charles arsenor va y
va y
revenir merci président merci très
chaleureusement à nos trois intervenants
euh un petit mot pour alin RTIL dont je
me souviens qu'il fut il y a très
exactement 20 ans d'ailleurs un brillant
pédagogue à Sciences Po avant d'être le
brillant chercheur qu'il est aujourd'hui
il était déjà chercheur d'ailleurs à
l'époque euh voilà euh évidemment ma
question ira vers madame le gourial qui
est vers vers l'Est euh deux ou trois
remarques sur ce qui a pu être dit sur
Djibouti et une question sur l'Éthiopie
voilà euh approche globale je ne peux
que qu'appuyer votre propos cé
d'ailleurs finalement la conclusion un
peu générale de de mon récent rapport
sur la
question une approche développement une
approche en matière
d'investissement qui est évidemment une
demande très forte de la partie
jbousienne une remarque sur le Global
Gateway vous avez dit à juste titre on
en parle assez peu en France donc c'est
peu lisible pour les partenaires
Européens eux-mêmes ce n'est pas lésible
non plus et je l'ai entendu de la part
de la partie jipousienne par les
jibousien non plus voilà donc on on a
quand même un sujet de clarification sur
l'ambition euh et la vision de l'Europe
dans la Corne de l'Afrique ça peut
peut-être amener un commentaire et
d'ailleurs peut-être de vous trois euh
autre remarque
euh oui donc je reprends à mon compte
bien volontiers le terme de guerre de
cours outil pour aller dans le sens de
notre collègue socialiste il y aura
certainement des évolutions à avoir sur
Atalante et Agénor on a pas cité Agor
mais c'est s là que ça va converger car
en effet il faudra probablement mieux
protéger et convoyer les navires qui
passent par les Détroit à cet endroit un
point peut-être
sur l'importance de la jeunesse vous
avez dit Madame le courrielc à juste
titre on ne décè pas encore à ce stade
de sentiments antirrançais c'est vrai
mais méfions-nous tout de même d'abord
ça peut se manipuler facilement et
rapidement les opinions changent vite et
ce pays est extrêmement jeune et le
point sur lequel je voudrais attirer
l'attention c'est la question de la
Francophonie qui est en fort déclin dans
le pays et donc parlant d'approche
globale il faut évidemment qu'on
investisse beaucoup sur l'apprentissage
du français dans ce pays c'est en tout
cas une conviction forte que je défends
et donc question sur l'Éthiopie
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire aujourd'hui
avec le président Aby Ahmed euh en effet
prix Nobel de la paix en 2019 mais
engagé dans des guerres extrêmement diff
difficile euh et encore reprise
aujourd'hui avec de lourds problèmes
avec les amaras euh la France s assez
largement rapprochée il y a quelques
années de l'Éthiopie aujourd'hui c'est
plus
compliqué peutons avoir une politique
française vis-à-vis de l'Éthiopie voilà
d'autant plus qu'on a le siège de
l'Union africaine à addisabeba donc
c'est particulièrement important madame
le
gorilc je rejoins tout à fait vos
remarques effectivement sur à la fois la
difficulté parfois d'européaniser parce
que nos partenaires en général sur le
continent ne comprennent pas toujours ce
que ça veut dire qui est devant nous et
ils ont souvent une demande de bilatéral
voilà nous on veut continuer à parler
avec les Français ou avec les Allemands
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette histoire
d'européanisé avec qui on va parler même
si souvent ce sont des Français qui
représentent l'Europe l'Union européenne
à Djibouti donc oui il y a un problème
de communication politique de
clarification à avoir sur les projets
vous imaginez que si c'est peu médiatisé
et peu connu en France nos partenaires
sur le continent ben c'est pareil il se
pose la donc il y a un vrai problème de
communication et alors que l'ambition
est là et qu' a vraiment une proposition
européenne et qu'il faut sûrement avoir
une volonté politique de la porter et de
de faire quelque chose oui pas de
sentiment anti-français et comme on l'a
vu dans d'autres régions ça peut être
manipulé euh on l'a vu également en
Éthiopie où justement le pays a toujours
joué d'une sorte de de de
multilatéralité et donc d'avoir
plusieurs partenaires et a toujours
privilégié ses différents partenaires et
à chaque fois que les Occidentaux avec
plein de guillemets mais en tout cas
voilà le les alliés les européens
américains et cetera on essaie de mettre
un peu la pression à bermed pendant le
conflit
euh il y avait des manifestations
d'organiser avec des drapeaux russes
donc pour nous rappeler que attention on
peut se tourner vers d'autres
partenaires euh donc c'est c'est ça ça
va être une vraie difficulté pour nos
démocratie justement de de savoir manier
cela qu'est-ce qu'on doit faire face à
ça ça va être un vrai problème et je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec vous euh
sur la la l'inpect francophonie
effectivement à Djibouti sur le il faut
insister moi je l'entends depuis une
dizaine d'années que ça chute ils ont dû
rajouter un examen postback sur le
français donc là c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui peut à moindre coût j'allais
dire me semble-t-il pour porter vraiment
la langue
française à Djibouti et dans la région
la question que vous me posez sur Que
faire avec Aby Ahmed le Premier ministre
Aby
Ahmed je je ne saurais véritablement pas
y répondre euh parce que tout simplement
je sais que la France a continuer à
garder beaucoup de liens avec l'Éthiopie
pendant le conflit je crois que des
entreprises françaises sont allées
là-bas dernièrement que ça fait partie
justement de
cette de cette Afrique non
traditionnelle pour nous vers laquelle
je j'invite à à investir et que une fois
que l'Éthiopie donc on a en France on
voit souvent l'Éthiopie comme les les la
famille des années 80 mais on oublie
toute la période de développement qu'il
y a eu lieu qui a eu lieu dans les
années 2000-20 c'est une future
puissance du continent africain ils ont
intégré les bricks euh mais comment
gérer effectivement politiquement à
bermed je pense qu'il faudra beaucoup
pousser sur la justice il faut qu'il y
ait une justice face au 3 ans de
conflits qui ont eu lieu et le conflit
ne le le pays ne pourra se reconstruire
et euh l'Éthiopie ne pourra être une ou
fédérale mais ne pourra se construire la
nation éthiopienne que en en ayant une
justice après ce qui s'est passé donc je
pense que la France et l'Union
Européenne peuvent accompagner et
pousser àmed sur ce
chemin très bien est-ce que Monsieur til
ou Benantar vous avez un point rajouté
sur francophonie ou euh global Gateway
est-ce que est-ce que global Gateway a
un sens en enfin que que quelle est la
pertinence de globale getto en Afrique
de l'Ouest par exemple alors on le voit
pas encore vraiment émerger
malheureusement mais je vais je vais me
concentrer sur la la disons sur le sur
la partie
francophonie que Monsieur le Député
Larsonneur a a évoqué euh élève alors d'
ce conours oui oui oui oui euh
c'est c'est c'est un des paradoxes de la
politique africaine de la France
vis-à-vis de enfin de la politique
africaine de la France et de assez peu
s'appuyer sur la sur sur la francophonie
sur les institutions de la Francophonie
d'abord mais ensuite plus
largement de s'être un peu désengagé de
de de de de l'enseignement supérieur de
de tout un tas de de coopérations alors
qu'il y a une demande très très forte
euh
sur l'enseignement sur la coopération
scientifique sur l'accès à des
ressources scientifiques en ligne il y a
une une véritable appétence du français
de la coopération avec la France sur ces
aspects dans les pays francophones
d'ailleurs comme dans les pays non
francophones hein je vois de dans dans
les pays d'Afrique de l'Ouest qui sont
entourés de pays français il y a une
demande de de de français tout
simplement pour pouvoir communiquer avec
ses avec ses voisins et euh si si on
regarde un peu les chiffres des des ce
qu'on appelait à l'époque les coopérants
français qui étaient assez nombreux dans
les dans les institutions de de de
formation on a on a beaucoup désinvesti
ce ce secteur alors que c'est un secteur
de c'est un levier d'influence
considérable quand vous parlez avec des
des des pardon d'être anecdotique mais
c'est ça ça donne un peu de chair disons
à mon propos quand vous parlez avec des
gens qui ont la quarantaine ou la
cinquantaine il y a dans dans certains
pays d'Afrique de l'ouest ils ont ils
ont tous la nostalgie d'un prof français
qui les a marqué ou de de de choses
comme ça
et c'est beaucoup moins vrai pour les
générations qui suivent ça c'est une
réflexion qu'il faut mener très très
fortement c'est on a on a un levier
naturel de de d'influence dont on se
sert finalement assez
peu très bien merci voir même parfois on
appelle nous-même des événements avec
des noms anglais donc faut qu'on fasse
attention également à ça nous av une
question de Mélanie tomin je crois que
ce sera potentiellement la dernière sauf
si ah voilà et on en aura une autre
après mais on aura trois autres as
autant pour moi vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président
Madame et messieurs merci pour vos
propos qui sont passionnants ce matin
vous avez beaucoup évoqué à travers les
échanges la Corne de l'Afrique et la
place forte que constitue Djibouti et je
voulais
revenir sous certains aspects et sous un
certain angle sur cette question
stratégique de la Corne de l'Afrique on
évoque beaucoup beaucoup l'influence
sinorus sur le continent africain on se
questionne aussi sur la présence de la
France dans cette zone je souhaitais
revenir à travers une question toute
simple sur la question du Moyen-Orient
dans quelle mesure les pays du
Moyen-Orient voisins de par leur
proximité géographique ont-ils eux aussi
une influence sur cette corne de
l'Afrique vous avez cité au début de vos
propos les Émirats le rôle des émirats
notamment comme un part comme un
partenaire un pays partenaire pour
Djibouti et l'axe de la mer Rouge
également stratégique donc comment
Afrique et Moyen-Orient communique
dialogue et comment s'organise les flux
entre ces deux territoires je vous
remercie alors merci m'attendez pas une
telle influence de de questions pour
terminer l'audition donc je vous propose
de de prendre les autres et
éventuellement de faire chacun une
réponse consolidée si possible en
restreignant la question autour de de
une minute notre la parole est à notre
collègue François pimal merci monsieur
le Président merci à vous pour ses ses
présentations et ses exposés nous on se
réjouit d'entendre évidemment que la
francophonie peut être un levier pour
demain dans les relations entre la
France et les pays de l'Afrique on
regrette d'ailleurs qu'il ait eu la
suspension des visas en provenance du
Sahel l'été dernier et on se réjouit que
certaines lois ne passent pas qui
auraient restreinte la francophonie à à
moyen ou à long terme entre la France et
les autres pays je vais venir sur sur le
Mali puisque le fait marquant là de ces
derniers jours c'est le départ officiel
de la minusma avec quand même 180 morts
de son côté sur les années où elle a été
engagée je crois plus de 15000 soldats
ou en tout cas personnel engagé et
finalement j'aimerais bon savoir ce que
vous en pensez mais peut-être pour aller
plus loin parce que vous avez quand même
donner déjà des éléments dessus quel
rôle peuvent avoir les pays africains
avec l'ONU et quel rôle peut avoir l'ONU
vis-à-vis des pays africains voilà je
serais curieux d'avoir vos réponses je
dois faire court donc je m'arrête ici
très bien merci la parole est à
Jacqueline
Maquet merci monsieur le Président merci
Madame et messieurs pour ces différents
exposés ma question s'adresse à Monsieur
antil en considérant l'approche
collaborative à la sécurité mise en
avant par le président Macron qui
englobe la formation l'équipement et le
soutien des forces de sécurité africaine
ainsi que la coopération renforcée en
matière de renseignement et de de lutte
contre le terrorisme comment
évaluez-vous l'impact potentiel de ce
modèle de partenariat sur la stabilité à
long terme en Afrique plus
spécifiquement dans quelle mesure cette
transition vers un modèle où les pays
africains sont en première ligne des
opérations sécuritaires avec l'appui de
la France et de ses partenaires
européens pourrait-elle influencer sur
la sécurité en Europe merci merci la
parole est à Karine
benchek
oui merci je vais essayer d'aller vite
et me concentrer plutôt sur le Sahel
c'est est-ce que nous pourrions imaginer
que les politique européenne de
contrainte des mobilités sahéliennes que
vous connaissez bien notamment vers le
nord ont pu participer à la
marginalisation du Sahel et à sa
déconnexion de sa rive nord historique
que sont les pays du Maghreb et par
ailleurs vous avez abordé en partie cela
mais est-ce que le démantellement de la
diplomatie française qui s'appuyait dans
la région notamment sur un réseau
constitué vous avez raison de plusieurs
milliers de opérant qui ont disparu avec
le la disparition du ministère de la COP
qui s'appuyait aussi sur un réseau de
diplomate spécialistes de la zone a pu
jouer un rôle est-ce que tout ce
démantellement a pu jouer un rôle est-ce
que le fait que la France a investi
moins de 3 % de ses moyens de
coopération au Sael ces 10 dernières
années a participé à cette perte de pied
de la France et enfin est-ce que la fin
de la diplomatie de métier du coup vous
paraît de bonne augure merci enfin une
toute petite intervention d'Oren
saintoule oui très bref euh on n pas
parlé des États-Unis et donc j'aimerais
que vous vous entendre sur la relation
qui existe entre la France les
États-Unis et les États africains je
pense évidemment au changement de pied
ou en tout cas l'attitude spécifique des
États-Unis au Niger qui nous a laissé un
peu isolé à la façon dont le chef de
Filat français exercé au Sahel pouvait
se concevoir et se conçoit largement
aussi comme une forme de délégation par
les États-Unis dans le casre de des
relations par exemple qui existait entre
minusma et et Barkan on sait que
certains éléments de des membres de la
minusma notamment allemand référait
régulièrement plutôt en cadre autant que
dans un cadre réellement africain ou
onusien donc voilà j'aimerais vous
entendre sur ces sujets là merci alors
il nous reste moins de 5 minutes
puisqueensuite nous devrons monter en
commission des affaires étrangères c'est
pourquoi je vous propose de piocher dans
les questions avec une ou de minutes
d'intervention chacun peut-être qu'on
peut commencer dans l'ordre inverse des
des présentations initiales avec
Monsieur benantard si vous souhaitez
commencer sur la question qui vous
intéresse concernant le le Moyen-Orient
et l'Afrique il y a il y a une euh un
certain discours en tous les cas des
analyses qu'on on rencontre de plus en
plus dans le golf sur la nécessité de de
de de de développer les relations avec
la cor d'Afrique considéré comme comme
la profondeur stratégique du golf en
essayion de en fait de réactiver des des
liens très anciens entre la côte Est et
et et et le Moyen-Orient mais le golf
n'agit pas en tant qu'ensemble puisqu'il
n'existe pas en tant qu'ensemble comme
l'Union européenne donc il y a des
rivalités entre les les états entre
l'Arabie Saoudite les Émirats arabe uni
et et arabe uni et et et et le Qatar les
trois euh se servent de de de levier de
d'influence économique à savoir
l'investissement mais en fait il y a une
sorte de euh de partage des rôles le cas
Qatar s'intéresse davantage à la
médiation au Soudan mais en Éthiopie
aussi les Émirats leur stratégie
portuère et les Saoudiens une stratégie
à la fois un peu économique mais un peu
religieuse aussi donc c'est c'est une
région en tous les cas qui qui intéresse
énormément de les pays du les pays du
golf sur le le Mali la minusma ça a été
évoqué par vous par quelqu'un d'autre
aussi désolé j'ai pas retenu le nom euh
évidemment c'est c'est une mission qui
qui qui ne fonctionnait pas très bien
qui en fait il y avait des problèmes de
rivalité et on voit les limites de la
coopération internationale avec les
Africains
et par exemple pour l'échange de
renseignement
euh les pays européens notamment
l'Allemagne mais mais l'Allemagne mais
d'autres aussi préfèrent le standard de
l'Alliance atlantique parce queil est
plus élevé que le le standard onusien et
de fait le le partage du renseignement
se faisait entre les Européens mais pas
avec les africains avec lesquels on est
censé travailler donc en terme de
contingence son le son le il constitue
la la la plus grosse partie du
contingent mais en terme du contrôle des
opérations ils sont marginalisés on
revient à la problématique de la la
propriation et et et l'africanisation
très rapidement sur la déconnexion Sahel
Maghreb il y a une déconnexion plus ou
moins vous en tous les cas historique
les pays maghrébains étai jusqu'à une
époque très récente et totalement tourné
vers vers le nord ils ont oublié sur
leur profondeur africaine ça fait à peu
près 10 ans qu'il y a une une une
refonte un peu de cette politique euh
maghrébine en Afrique le Maroc d'abord
puis puis l'Algérie mais n'en demeure
pas moins que l'Union européenne joue un
rôle qui qui force un peu la relation la
à travers
l'externalisation de la gestion
migratoire et et et et frontalière
l'Union européenne intervient dans dans
la définition dans la définition des
relations du Maghreb avec son voisinage
immédiat à savoir ça ilen dans le sens ù
des espaces qui étaient là des espaces
de mobilité jusqu'à le rouvert ont été
fermés et les Maghrébins les pays
maghriébins
instoreent le système des visas
souspression européenne mais aussi ils
ont des intérêts aussi en la matière
donc infi l'Union européenne participe
de la d'un processus de déconnexion
entre ces deux ensembles africains je je
merci merci merci désolé on a un temps
très contraint madame le Gourel un peu
moins d'une minute euh je vais juste
juste clarifier juste un point euh donc
les pays du Golf ont toujours eu des
relations avec les pays de la Corne de
l'Afrique les Émirats n'ont plus de rel
enfin si ont des relations mais ne sont
plus à Djibouti ça n'est pas un
partenaire puisque Djibouti a
nationalisé son port et renvoyé les les
Émirats euh néanmoins les Émirats
contrôlent une bonne partie des ports de
la mer Rouge et que ce soit l'Iran la
Turquie et cetera sont présents dans la
Corne de l'Afrique merci pour la brifté
enfin al antil oui de manière très
lapidaire et je m'excuse de pas répondre
à toutes les questions sur la minusma la
minusma son mandat c'était de d'appuyer
les Accords
d'Alger vu que le respect des accords
d'Alger n'est pas l'objectif politique
de du du Mali cette mission n'avait plus
raison d'être d'une certaine manière on
peut le déplorer euh je je
note je note que l'année 2023 est
l'année où on a annoncé la fin des deux
plus grosses opérations de de de l'ONU
en Afrique c'est-à-dire la la minusma et
la Monusco donc on est en train de
parser dans une autre phase il y a il y
a d'autres demandes sur l'approche
collaborative les les les annonces qui
ont été faites par l'exécutif français
sur passer en deuxième ligne appuyer
sont moins exposantes politiquement et
vraisemblablement on va dans le bon sens
en annonçant ce ce ce type de
d'implication par rapport à la question
de Monsieur Karim
bencher effectivement il y a une
réflexion à faire autour de notre
appareil diplomatique euh il me semble
ces dernières années c'est ce que j'ai
perçu que les les postes de diplomate en
Afrique sont pas les plus valorisés dans
auqu d'orset il y a une réflexion à
avoir sur ce point merci et sur France
US Niger pendant la guerre froide il y a
eu un partage des tâches entre entre les
États-Unis l'Angleterre et la France sur
certaines zones la France occupait de de
l'Afrique francophone il est probable
que les États-Unis ne jugent plus la
France capable de mener à bien certaines
missions en Afrique francophone très
bien ben merci à tous les trois désolé
pour ce temps très contraint j'étaéis
surpris par les cinq dernières questions
qui n'étaient pas prévues et on se
retrouve mes chers collègues tout de
suite pour l'édition Dubert viedrine en
salle de la commission des affaires
étrangères merci beaucoup